[Music]
we're rolling hey we might be drunk we
might be gay we're ambiguous we got
Superman here Super Jew that's beard Jew
salaku Gambit we got a wolverine Jew
it's Halloween man um oh that's the dog
dude what's that Millie Winnie Winnie
can I pet the dog real quick of course
pet the
dog oh my God isn't that cute oh what so
can what's the story how old she's 16
gay o Epstein she's on the fence yeah I
think all dogs are gay or a little bit
all most animals I don't I think she's
honestly asexual she's just kind of
she's just kind of a cold [__] to
anyone who comes near her she nice to me
if all dogs go to heaven then they can't
be gay oh all right so you guys are
doing coffee but we'll get into a drink
I mean we need energy but yeah we're
doing we're drinking too okay uh thanks
for having me back back guys we we were
excited I mean I saw you in Charlotte a
few a few a couple months ago thanks for
lunch that was awesome was fun that was
a good crew he was on tour I was doing a
movie there we met up I couldn't come to
a show cuz I was working that night but
we Tony uh cavaler that's right Tony oh
he's hot you know you know him from um G
righteous gemstones he played aie
Osborne in the that movie The Dirt he's
awesome really funny comedic actor he
comes from an improv background stand
but he's a big fan of yours he was so
stuck to meet you that was so fun man
the whole crew uh can I eat these
candies in these days you got to ask
everyone cuz of drugs in candies fol we
got a tester oh [__] hold on funp funp
was this was like drugs for kids
remember those it really was your first
dipping in a powder bag um do you guys
are not La guys but you've been to
Hollywood Boulevard and you've seen the
guys that walk around in the Soggy sad
suit that looks like like they want to
be a superhero but it's like the butt's
dirty and it's soggy and they're skinny
they like a dirty Pokemon nobody pays
them they're just doing
I feel like that guy because your dick
is showing a little
bit I got a small like right now it's
super small it feels like it's showing
pretty big red rocket dude well that was
a Prost fake it was a hammer it was a
hammer was it fun Ro because I had to
put my big dick in a smaller dick so
that was
uncomfortable um no it was uh it was
very awkward putting on the prosthetic
penis yes it was the director's the
director's uh fiance Who was the
producer of the movie Samantha Quan had
to we had to get intimate pretty quick
cuz she had to like literally I would
put my penis in this other dick and she
would like very very independent film so
just basically like paste it around my
crotch and balls and we had to do a test
where I had to jog in place and see if
it flopped realistically it was awesome
oh it was awesome and she's Asian yeah
so that must have been bigger yeah Quan
that's yeah U so yeah that was Shan
Baker's fiance and she did so thank you
Sam Dewan there you go yeah when I got I
tore my sack in college jumping a
and they they had to stitch it up but of
course they brought the hot nurse in
with my tiny Acorn cuz I'm you know I'm
in a doctor's room it's cold I'm nervous
so my ball bag's being sewn up and then
the nurse came in and put a gel on it
and I was like get hard no I was too
ashamed cuz how bad it looked this
explains a lot of uh women issues you
have yeah a lot of but you got to sit in
the hot blonde you know 22-year-old I
had that with a you know I had a thing
on my dick a while back and the and the
hot they were like oh we have our
student can she watch and I'm like can I
see a picture first H hot chick really
yeah she watched she watched W and of
course you're shriveled as hell I'm like
it's not like it's like it's a bad dick
day bad dick day it's like a it's a full
interview it's like your dick's First
Open Mic it's not ready that grower
shower thing is real like I got a couple
friends who are just always packing heat
like 24/7 and then people like myself
who have a little dick that can get big
okay so so there's both and then it's
the guys with the permanent big hog that
are just like dude that must give you
the big dick energy so much more to know
it's just showing in your pants and you
could get pants at any moment and you're
like I'm good so like yeah I I was at a
Comedy Festival recently and they do the
naked roast which I don't know why
anyone was signed up for that who's
naked everyone or just the victim just
the victims and the host and the the
judges remember Kur me had a line about
that roast where he goes just write
jokes I know like how hard is it to just
write jokes well they did have jokes but
but I know what you mean oh look at this
we got blood brilant that good
dude the Gambit outfit I'm a tequila guy
awesome this is great cheers Boys Hey
mle now uh we might be drunk now what is
the uh is it Kool-Aid what do you got in
there oh no I just donated my own blood
just P grapefruit juice right Magic
Johnson's blood [__] oh God he's still
going that's pretty good ah oh boy
trying to put down this coffee so I can
drink this Blood yeah let me kill this
hey yeah so coffee and alcohol yes so
this is this the point of day usually
where coffe transitions into alcohol or
is it different every day no we usually
don't drink this early I mean unless
we're podcasting that's what I mean yeah
usually it's the pot the Pod the Pod
will force us but uh so what have you
been up to you you back in the movie the
world or you yeah back in the movie
world but I can't so it's funny uh I had
to remind myself on the way over here
I'm you know because of this strike that
uh you know could be over any now for
the SAG part the the writer strike's now
over so you see SNL's coming back all
the talk shows are coming back we were
just asking how come SNL is allow it to
come back if sag is not complete because
also like Fon and some of the other talk
shows are coming back I think it's the
gray area between it not being writing
for an actor so it's not really sag
because they're not actors they're hosts
even though they also act I believe that
I'm not smart enough to know this is
just what I think that there's still the
that sort of the gray area where okay
now we could do talk shows and then
eventually scripted actor show show as
well got it okay that makes sense so
yeah anyway I'm just glad shit's opening
up but I I'm not allowed to talk about
all this cool [__] I did but I am
allowed to talk about one that was so
this is how it works is is Sag has to
give you like basically waiver like give
you the hall pass to talk about or
promote online a movie that you did in
do press so I'm here for the New York
Film Festival uh and I got a movie
called The Sweet East which is a really
cool Indie that was just in can so I was
back in can it's so fun how I got into
this like artsy fartsy like you know
actor world uh cuz after red rocket I'm
doing these cool Indies so this one is
sort of in that same world like shot on
film do you ever see a movie called good
time yeah it's brother remember how cool
that movie was great movie part of the
[__] coolness of that movie was it
was shot so beautifully by this DP
Director of Photography uh named Sean
Price Williams he's the guy who shot
that movie and if you wanted a cool a24
movie or you're in Europe and you want a
french artistic movie this is the guy
you want to shoot your movie so I metab
can when I was there 3 years ago for red
rocket and he said I got a movie I'm
doing my first directorial debut and I
just knew it would be cool cuz he's such
a good cinematographer and I knew he was
such a film nerd that he would make a
cool movie and then I read the script
and I play a white supremacist uh
Professor who's a Nazi sympathizer who
gets to drop serious bad offensive words
that you can't say anymore I'm like I'm
in wow and I'm Jewish so it was fun to
play Nazi symp it's going to confuse the
haters here oh yeah dude now what about
those people like hey you going to have
a trans person you got to be played by a
trans person are we going to go to the
point where n you got to have a real
Nazi oh that's a good question not in
this case I guess not they got the exact
opposite yeah so exactly so but that was
fun to play that so anyway the movie is
called the sweet East it's U that's why
I'm here in New York promoting it and uh
hell yeah canell people they need to
play a real rapist like we bring them
back right that's right how we get them
back yeah they got to work Jim Jeffrey
said a great bit about like well you
have to be trans to play a trans person
but what about all the good-looking
people who are playing ugly people like
Charlie's Thon is monster that's right
that should go to a real Ugo a real
Monster yeah exctly That's progress yes
oh there it is okay so there's uh that's
is this the film that Tony's in as well
no this that one we just shot that's
another movie that I my first I actually
I got my first producer credit on that
one so funny I just had to ask like I've
been acting for 25 [__] years I've
never got the respect it's always like
stand here say this wear this say it
like this which is fine but you you know
I got ideas I'm not you know I sometimes
they better than the writer's ideas just
being honest and I in this movie I was I
simply said hey I want to be a producer
on it and they go okay that's all I had
to do this whole [__] time so I had
input on my wardrobe I had input on
rewrites I'd be on set punch like
pitching jokes they put him in the movie
I was like this is awesome um you know
you see some actors who kind of take it
to that level of like producing as well
that's kind of what I want to do cuz you
know so much [__] out there so bad oh
yeah that I feel like I I got some ideas
hell yeah you've been in the game long
enough I'm not just a [__] you know
Jewish face well you got a nice mug
thanks but yeah yeah good for you cuz
that's what I don't like about acting is
you have no control you have no input
you know they just tell you do what they
say to say on the paper literally have a
mark go to that literally stand there
wear this so so but some depends on the
project there's been some projects where
they give you some wiggle room to improv
and that's always when like the best
[__] happens is when you're letting it
Fly and agree so so in this movie though
the sweet East I was very much I had to
stick to the script this guy Nick
Pinkerton wrote it who's a very famous
New York film critic that all the ciles
know and he was he a a super
intellectual intelligent guy when I read
my lines I had to Google like every
other words I didn't know what the [__]
it meant he was so smart so he's a film
critic he's a film critic who wrote this
movie
it's insane yeah and it's that's kind of
ballsy cuz now CU now your next if you
want to go back to criticism then
they're like well your movie might have
sucked it's like it's like a Jew playing
a Nazi Roger Eber wrote Beyond the
Valley of the Dolls really is that right
whoa Eber was a great writer true I mean
he really you read his reviews are
incredibly well well if this guy gets
trashed you're like hey welcome to the
club so anyway the Talia Ryder who
you're looking at right there she's the
lead she's a great uh awesome young
actor and uh so this one was very much I
had to stick to the script not a lot of
wiggle room but it's okay it worked for
this movie but then the movie you're
talking about in Charlotte I did it's
it's called operation Taco Garry's and
it's coming out um don't know when we
just saw the first cut it's so funny it
basically we wanted to do a throwback
comedy cuz I'm sure you guys will
appreciate this there's no more good
silly comedies in the world of like
those '90s 2000 comedies that are just
you could put your brain under your seat
for 90 minutes and just have a laugh and
not take yourself so seriously or be too
woke or be too politically correct or be
too this and that we just went for it
and so yeah I um yeah it's called Uh
operation Taco
Gary producer credit that one is not a
can no it won't be a can that one will
be a garbage can just
kidding actually like this one a lot I
love it I just saw the first cut and
it's really [__] funny and the cast
is great and it so oh wait I don't know
if I'm allowed to talk about that one
but I just did [__] it well we can cut
anything out later but is I'm sorry Mark
go no I just think the world is craving
that silly comedy again yeah yeah yeah
exactly no Simon is like a legit Avid
listener of this podcast he'll text me
he'll text me like less guests I want
more than you you and Mark oh and then
but then he'll hit me up he's like I
want to come back on them so we got
we're happy you're back cuz he's like a
Critic of our pod it's actually kind of
pathetic it's it's weird because you
guys and a few other Comics I realized
like me and a lot of other dudes out
there I'm sure you guys know this now
you guys have become come kind of our
soap opera like we know your guys live
so well from listening to the Pod and we
know who's got beef with who and who did
this and who slept with a [__] this
week and this and that and it's turning
this thing where me and my boys are
hitting each other up like did you hear
the like as if we know you guys and I'm
sort of in the diagram where I kind of
do know you guys but it's it's really
become this thing where a lot of guys my
age and I'm sure younger and older um
you guys have become truly like a part
of our life we listen to you when we're
traveling in the car on the way to
it's like you're for instead of a middle
housewife watching Days of Our Lives we
know you guys lives now watch that [__]
I have a girl who watches like I come
home it's like Beyond deck on Bravo I'm
like this is [__] what whatever how
dare you yeah it's [__] trash well
[__] makes you dumber yeah I'm Aid
listener I know you guys so well and
it's funny cuz normally out and this
sounds arrogant but normally out in the
world people kind of know like if I meet
someone I don't know that well they know
more about me than I know about them of
course and that's how it is with you
guys I know so much more about you guys
than you know about me well we met
during Co we just like kind of became
Pals during Co but uh I mean since then
I've like you know been watching I mean
red rocket is such a you given insane
performance man like we've said on the
Pod you deserved an Oscar nomination I
mean these Awards things are [__]
anyway but like you know you were you
were so good in that and and there's
like a narrative to those things so now
maybe that you got that one under your
belt it's like you'll get it for the
next one or something yeah maybe I you
know it's funny I never it's just funny
that that was I remember when that came
out there was a lot of Oscar buzz around
that movie but Sean Baker the director
writer producer editor he told me he
goes here's what's going to happen and
he was totally right he goes uh you were
going to get a great Buzz for this we'll
probably win a spirit award which we did
we'll win some Festival Awards but the
academy won't go near it because of the
subject matter it's about you grooming a
girl who's 17 years old they're going to
run the other way a lot of the voters
are still very involved in that type of
stuff that I'm just kidding I think the
voters are still involved in that
behavor they want to run the other way
it's a documentary so it was I think it
was a little heavy subject matter for
the Academy but like theend Spirit
awards they're cool with it and they
loved it and we got uh good so we got
some cool Awards and it was just funny
re it was um not this sounds like
[__] but I remember like the first
time someone shared an article with me
and they're like uh these Oscar pundits
that like predict who's going to win the
Oscar and I was like Simon Rex 6% I'm
like the fact that I'm even in this
conversation is [__] hilarious k i I
have such low self-esteem I really
people gamble on that huh people gamble
on that it's a real thing my friend Dave
J Will gamble on the [__] Tony that's
manly and gay at the same time kind of
like us right yeah we're we're ambiguous
yeah yeah yeah wow good for you 6%
that's not well that was just for me I
was like that's funny and that's that's
enough and then the reality of like what
that meant was actually kind of scary
because I still ride the subway like I
rode the subway yesterday I still I flew
coach out here cuz I had to get my own
ticket and I'm not that Rich yeah I
still want to be able you guys talk
about this on the Pod you don't want to
get too famous to where you fly too
close to the Sun you want to kind of
cruise to where you can still fly coach
still take the subway and not be noticed
and that's where I'm at in my career and
I was like dude a Oscar nomination would
put me in that no Subway I got to get
first class now category there's some
osc look up some Oscar winners Matt
don't you think there's some Oscar
winners who like we who people we know
but people don't really know it's ch it
used to be much more of thing I feel
like now no one cares as much but I mean
like did how many people saw tar like
that's an a Claim movie right exactly
right it's like right yeah that's what
that's that's what's become so funny is
that all the biggest like Oscar buzz
movies like no one seen them yeah it's
like late night for us Simon which uh
actor do you sort of I like their career
like this is the career I want to have
you know that's a good question but I
really you okay oh you know what Bill
Murray because he's never once you've
never really seen him do something that
you're like that sucks or if he is a
part of something it's not that's not
the best it's not because of him and
he's just steadily like he'll always do
a cool Indie movie he'll do like he just
kind of does what he wants to do like I
saw him at can when I was out there and
everyone's in a suit and he's in a
flowered shirt and he just don't give a
[__] I love it yeah he's like one of the
last OG kind of like [__] you I don't
like guys left like Nicholson maybe yeah
Nicholson but he's not around as much
you don't see him out as much he was out
a couple Lakers games though but it was
like it was sad that it was like a big
deal that out it's like Winnie being out
you're like [__] it's sad that this is
like the sunglasses are just cuz he's
seeing impaired well so I would say Bill
Murray to me has the ideal career
because like he's just always does cool
[__] he's just who he wants to be and he
just stays working he'll just do a
couple movies a year that would be the
dream but um not comparing myself to him
at all he's just that dope and then I I
was really lucky so it was funny when we
were in can um we uh up for for red
rocket we uh how it works is you wait in
your hotel room to see if you win best
movie best actor Best Director all this
stuff and in can it's called the palm
toor and it's the top eight movies I
believe of the year are in that category
so red rocket was in that category which
automatically it's a win you're in like
the top eight movies of the year and
there was actually Buzz going around
that we could win best actor best movie
all this stuff and it went down to the
very last second we're waiting in our
hotel room and we didn't get it by like
a very small margin the jury whatever
spele was in the jury it was the whole
thing anyway the the production company
was with Bill Murray and they go we feel
so bad you got robbed we're taking you
out tonight with a surprise and I go to
dinner and Bill Murray shows up to
dinner Bill Murray sits next to me puts
his hand on my leg and he's like so red
rocket huh he's like I'm just like what
is happening oh my Lord this is not
happening right now like and he was
being so funny and he was [__] with
the waiter and did I not tell this on
the last one I remember really [__] I'm
G to tell it
again dud the punch line is we hung out
all night we're walking through the
streets of France he's such a a cool guy
I see him at the Vanity Fair party a few
months later I go up to him like hey
Bill what's going on he looks me up and
down has no idea who I am takes his
rapper of his burger and puts it in the
inside of my jacket pocket and slaps me
on the chest and walks away that's
amazing I was like that's even cooler
that is so cool yeah just didn't
remember me he'll just show up to frap
parties and you know bars and buy
everybody around I did tell that story
but there'll be a few listeners that
didn't hear that last I know and dude
you're one of those dudes that was so
pumped wanted to come back because I
feel like the last episode I mean we
even cut some gold because we had to you
asked there was a couple things we
couldn't tell Charli Sheen oh really
okay but it was I mean the stories we
kept in were [__] gold good good good
yeah yeah uh well you know I think it's
also kind of like I know I I listen to
the show so much that I feel like I
could kind of just jump right in and
zing and Zang with you boys and uh I get
it some shows you go on it's like you
might not like right now I'm getting set
up with some podcast that I kind of got
to do the homework before and like
listen to it to get sort of the tone of
the show uh but yeah hate a podcast with
homework come on yeah I mean we'll give
you some peeves and recks but that's you
know some people get annoyed with that
even oh really that's the best [__] I
love how your guest the other day's dad
called in with some peeves who was it
your boy uh you had on yeah and his dad
had a peeve like Rick is a polarizing
guest you love him or you hate him good
numbers on that up though I got to say
he brings his people oh yeah he's got
the
weirdos um now uh yeah it was funny
because if you just listen to it and
don't watch it there was those pauses
that he was taking that you couldn't
tell if he was like if it was serious or
not which is entertaining and funny like
like he that's his stick right like he
was kind of doing this thing I'm like oh
if I'm watching this I think I'd pick up
on it more but I was driving and
listening but it was like a funny thing
he was doing with you guys where he was
like kind of breaking your balls and
acting like he was really upset or
whatever you know he was a little little
Frosty that day he came in hot yeah he
just did an earlier pod and he was he
was a little spicy the thing too
sometimes people come to the city and
they just like rack up pods in a day and
you're like number five and they come
and they're like what like you asked on
yeah you beg to get on here yeah but hey
so yeah what else so yeah I'm going back
to what you're saying though the the Rex
and the peeves that's one of the best
parts of the show and going back further
I did let you know once I think just as
a fan if anything when you have a guest
on it would I love hearing you two just
alone together that my note was maybe
you two guys do 10 minutes alone before
your guest in that that was just that's
just my horrible idea I like the note
now where did you grow up I grew up in
the Bay Area San Francisco Oakland
Berkeley Bay Area so did you do the the
trick-or-treating as a as a youth oh
yeah absolutely and I remember back it
was in the 80s uh uh that your parents
would have to go through all the candy
because there was I don't know if you
guys had New Orleans and New York where
there'd be like a razor blade is insane
because think about how expensive razor
blades are good point well it would
actually be helpful cuz you know razors
are not cheap you're hoping there's one
in there was that Nationwide fear that
there was like ra like that must have
been everywhere because I remember the
parents having to go through the candy
and make sure it was safe it's a weird
thing as like a villain like to get your
satisfaction not in front of you like I
hope somebody got [__] up yeah it's
like the lotto but like for scarring a
kid's face you got to watch the news
every night come on kid with another
Blood absolutely was Snopes on this this
time make it a Charlie
Sheen uh and uh it did happened once the
razor blade in the Apple but it was done
by the father to his own son whoa oh so
you can check out Snopes that's in there
the apple don't fall too far from Hey
there you go an apple a day it kill your
son we might be Marvin Gay oh baby uh so
yeah anyway that was my note to that
time I think I texted you and I was like
I love it when it's just you guys so
maybe there's a way to do both but uh I
guess it all depends on the guest but
you two just together is just so great
until someone like me comes in Hogs and
Mike and ruins the flow we like it man
heavy flow good flow love the flow drink
blood
anyway all right all right so wait okay
so yeah Halloween poison candy what else
Halloween Halloween those abductions are
you a horror movie guy not really you
know I'm not I I don't want to pay to be
I kind of live in fight ORF flight all
the time as a Jew anyway I'm always in
this state of like something bad's going
to happen so watching that to me it just
doesn't do it for me my life's kind of a
horror movie like I yeah not really but
in the that I'm you know like I feel
that I got to work very hard at like
relaxing it doesn't do it for me I'm
with you I I did see paranoia paranoid
what was it paranoid activity paranormal
I saw it in a black neighborhood and
that was pretty great all black theater
that was helpful that's always fun when
going to movies as a kid in Oakland was
the best cuz the crowd yelling at the
screen was half the fun I mean I've said
it before I saw American Pie in a in a
black neighborhood and he you know they
show the pie all mangled and some guy
goes he tore that [__] up and the
[__] place erupted popcorn went in
the air it was a it was a hoot in a Hol
start of a comedy career right there he
got his first laugh Adam Sandler said he
got his first laughs zinging in movies
really yeah yeah I probably told this
last time people always ask me like why
do I want to get in a show business
which I actually never did it kind of
just fortuitously fell in my lap but
when I was 12 years old I went to an
Oakland A's game and I was in the
bleachers it was $1 bleacher tickets and
I'm in the bleachers with my boys I
probably told this on the last one I
don't remember this and it cuts you know
when the camera cuts to someone in the
crowd so it cuts to me and my boys we're
12 and I double flip off the camera on
the Jumbotron and 32,000 people erupt in
laughter and I got this tingle obviously
that was like but it wasn't like at that
moment I'm like oh I'm going to go into
show business but it was sort of a core
memory or something that was like well
that was special like the cutway right
away but everyone was laughing and I was
like yeah you know I bet that lives on
the internet somewhere we got to find no
cuz this was 1989 or something there was
no nobody had yeah we had stavi and I
were on the board at the Liberty game
they put us on the screen yeah and I
know it took St of like every every
ounce of strength not to just
immediately
go you know but uh no we were on the on
the screen together was fun as hell but
like that moment as a comic you're like
do I want to get invited back did you
kiss I kind of wanted that would have
been awesome um I was just watching this
horror movie called I didn't it was I
don't like horror movies and this is
actually a peeve of mine it's it's a
really well-made movie it's a very good
movie It's called talk to me you can
look it up it's I think it's Australian
is it newer yeah I heard about it I've
heard it's really good 824 is killing it
exactly they make good [__] it's a it's
a really well-made movie I think it's
got crazy high Rotten Tomatoes too but
this is a peeve of mine and I like
horror when it's like either
psychological or like and this did have
an element to it that was psychological
but the premise is like there's a stone
hand that's cursed and you and you grab
it and you can let in dead spirits to
your body and you say uh you know talk
to me and then you allow the spirit in
but if you let them in too long they
overtape your body but it's like a drug
for the kids it's a smart premise my
issue is this there are bad signs
already and I don't like like like
there's enough Horror in your life to go
with you're saying when you bring upon
you this unnecessary [__] like there's I
there another peeve in horror movies
when the spirit takes over you and it's
like and then you see a person be like
run you know that's a peeve like
and you're like what what do we do this
been done to death I feel like but
that's in the movie The and then you
like all right but then they keep doing
it till more and more bad [__] happens
and you're like you see people are
suffering yeah yeah I don't like dumb
decisions I think I it's hard for me and
you know I'm watching my girl and she's
like they're kids and I'm like I know
but I think kids are [__] dumb I
think the point like scream had enough
like comic relief for me MH yes well to
me the supernatural [__] me up like
when they there's a comedy movie and
they're like but the kid made a wish and
it all came true and I'm like well now
I'm out of it that's exactly right
that's how I felt with Game of Thrones I
was in until dragons flew around thank
you as soon as dragons and white walkers
which is racist but I won't get into
that start walking around white uh I'm
out I'm out it's like then it's a Sci-Fi
thing and you're talking mystical Realms
just keep it to your brother's [__] and
your sister and you're going to get
decapitated I can relate to that dragons
fly around I'm I'm out I'm out you know
it is weird how much the brother and
sister [__] used to be a thing cuz I
I talked about this in the previous
episode but like the R Empire used to be
I mean it's online baby step bro all
that [__]
step you saying that number one looked
up a porn is Step family because some
people want to F their step sister I
thought it used to be I thought it was
step not Mom or oh step anything oh step
by step step by step step ladder yeah
you name it uh 12
steps that's an orgy but yeah so they uh
yeah but I think that goes back to like
Primal days of like [__] your sister
[__] your cousin that's all you had
when you were Village People all inbred
back in them days Romans had options I
think they were just like it was like
the arrogance of your bloodline I think
it was like I was watching one of them
and I think it was Caligula and he was
like uh he was like my sister and I are
are pregnant we're expecting it everyone
even then was like o except one guy was
like a toast I'm like that's a Survivor
that dude he knew what he had to
do the best thing about incest is you
already met the parents you know is that
just you came up with that that somebody
write that down Guess who's coming to
dinner but it's just a regular night of
dinner
exactly that's so funny yeah incest
that's good stuff I'm an only child so I
can't relate oh you got lucky or unlucky
right well i' so here's the thing only
child so I I I'm a mess but I had step
family so I shared my toys and I it
wasn't just like me but uh not by Blood
you know what I mean step brothers or
sisters I had uh two step families oh
man my mom's busy yeah so now my um uh I
growing up I had two Step Brothers in
San Francisco I'll tell you this guy's
got more steps than an Apple Watch and
uh one of my Step Brothers he was like a
savant like he was re he's like really
very very intelligent and he was
investing in the stock market when he
was 10 years old I never forget he would
he would buy like the product of the
stock he invested in and put it in the
window of our house in San Francisco
because in his mind it was a billboard
to promote that product to get more
sales now the numbers wise it's not
going to do that but to think that way
at 10us no he is and then we would go to
New York or San Francisco Giants games
and he would sit there and count every
stat and look in the chronicle the next
day and if they were wrong he'd call
them upset and be like you guys were
wrong about how many pitch like he was
like whatever I don't know what you call
that autism it yeah some form of it but
but hyper intelligent but you know like
yeah that is like what's he doing now
he's murdering people no he's counting
cards in Vegas yeah no he's in sales and
he has a bunch of kids in San Francisco
and he's just a good dude but he was
just like it was just interesting to see
like you know that way of thinking
because I'm just the opposite what do
you think of San Francis is it is it as
bad as they say on the news is it
apocalyptic are the business going away
is it fentanyl all day yeah you know I
was just actually out there I was
actually just with Pete I wanted to take
so Pete Davidson uh was doing standup up
there so I wanted to go take them out in
my hometown I'm like bro I'm always in
New York with you let me take you around
show you some good food was so [__]
he's just so famous we couldn't even go
get lunch we would try to go get lunch
and and nowadays with social media not
only do you get bum rushed with a photo
without them asking like this young
generation of kids now with the phone
they just come up and film you and tag
where you're at so you can't sit down
and have lunch because in five minutes
everyone's going to be showing up right
you know and San Francisco's not like a
show biz town so that's a big deal if
like Pete Davidson's having lunch
somewhere yeah so unfortunately we
didn't get to do it but so but uh to
your point I drove through the
tenderloin would you have them real
quick uh okay so there was a few places
there's a place called um uh Swan that's
like Swan oyster Depot yeah that's one
of the top ones always a line is the
problem and waiting line with him stuff
uh oyster and Depot is not a great
combination uh this is but it's just
like a real good
OG looks like Colin Quinn it's a real
like like blue collar place where
they're just shucking oysters and like
Sashimi style fish
and saw no it's really good and there's
a few other places I I'll mispronounce
that are like some Asian but anyway to
answer your question it's it's it's
shitty but it's no worse it's it is
definitely uh sensationalized in the
media they were so mad that cash app guy
didn't die from a
random you could tell that the media was
just like [__] we wanted this so bad
right he didn't die he died but it was
it was planned it wasn't like a random
oh right right right there are random
people that kill you but yeah so like
the murder rate is way worse in other
cities New Orleans sorry Miami you know
a lot of places so the murder rate's not
that crazy in San Francisco it's more
just like there's shitty crimes like
your car is going to get broken into
because of the the the very laxed laws
on like a theft under a thousand bucks
you don't go to jail so it's just green
light for everyone to Rob out of your
car which is like yeah that sucks um and
you see it on the clips everywhere and
it's uh it's shitty but it's still one
of the most beautiful cities I love it
great food great you know [__] great
place to grow up don't want to live
there anymore but like so much culture
there it's kind of like New York of
California we have everything we get
like you know it's like a urban
Metropolis you get every type of you
know sex race whatever come as you are
like whatever you know so good place to
grow up great place to grow up beautiful
city and the ners baby and the Warriors
baby we got good sport I mean uh the
Niners are looking incredible we're
looking incredible we just got to stay
healthy it's it's kind of nerve-wracking
when you're this good in the beginning
of the year you want to get good in the
second half of the year and not be uh
hurt so but they have the talent we got
the talent baby oh yeah and it's just
such a Disney movie like the whole
quarterback story is just so
unbelievable Brock Mr Irrelevant last
pick number three get rid of him and now
he's coming out there putting up like
MVP numbers it's kind of insane it's
like a Tom Brady story he's not as a Tom
Brady but he's like that kind of story
Bay Area oh Tom Brady's Bay Area exactly
and so I think my guy Julian Edelman is
a Bay Area guy oh who oh oh yeah I met
him the other day he was at pach show
the the wide receiver on the Patriots
Yeah he was a cool guy he was backstage
at Pete show in in La uh was shooting
[__] with him for a while we were
talking football and uh cool dude great
guy you don't want to fight that guy in
a bar he was just I thought he was a UFC
fighter when he first walked in he's
just built like a he will [__] you up
those are always the nicest guys the
[__] you up like UFC fighters always uh
like a like a gentle lamb of a-year-old
dog so relaxed CU they know they'll [__]
you up they don't it's the loud ones
that talk [__] are the ones that are
[__] usually I I was in Phoenix in
the fighter Kelvin gastam at the show oh
nicest guy
but he'll [__] I mean like he's
incredible as a and he comes in my Gren
after he's like one table just one shut
up I was like can you imagine getting
shush by a [__] just a badass
professional fighter and they like
you're like [__] off and he just like
stands up and you're like wow you don't
know cuz he doesn't look like like he's
going to kill you guy tiny guy but he
will [__] kill you yeah nowadays you
can't [__] because you don't just
know the cauliflower ear is sign number
one but a lot of times some of I
remember taking Jiu-Jitsu for a year and
then one day realizing I'm not this guy
but I tried it for a while and I
remember going into the class and being
like so many of these guys you would
never think and they will [__] you up
they don't look it AP part but like it
just goes to show you like it's true
it's like chyia you never know the dick
looks the same but it's in there that
the [__] is in there even a school
shooter you can tell like I bet that
guy's uh either way you're peeing blood
that's the point I uh yeah I did you
jitu for a year and it's like one of
those things where I like golfed for a
year or two and after a while so some
things in life you got to kind of find
out who you are by finding out who
you're not and after I remember I
remember I had this Epiphany I was in
Jiu-Jitsu class and I got this dude with
my arms behind my back like ready to
dislocate out of my shoulder and the
dude sitting on my face and I'm smelling
his [__] and I remember at that
moment I had a thought I go I'm paying
money for
this and I never went back again and you
pay money should be a woman really yeah
true true um and I said why am I why am
I doing this uh but you learned some
stuff learned a couple of things and
actually the one time I got in a fight
in 20 years I used it and it [__]
worked what happened in theight story
Bill Mur so I fly to Australia Bill what
Bill Murray you beat him up oh yeah yeah
um Muhammad Ali his last fight he got
him no so F I fly to Australia and as we
know Australians are ready to fight at
all times oh yeah fly to Australia I was
back when I was doing dirt nasty this
music comedy Persona
that late night your dick got the HIV I
remember oh did you just play I thought
I just I can we get another round of I
bloody IV are you Spider-Man under there
is Gambit who's G Gambit what is that
X-Men x- guy oh I I've never seen X-Men
I'm not he's Creole yeah he's oh so
they're becoming more cultural Marvels
yeah no there's an older one that's what
I call Bruce Jenner X-Men all right
there we go we're back that was good put
that down with the
incest all right keep going oh so anyway
I never forget because I was so mad at
my tour manager we flew to Australia
which is a very long [__] travel day
and we land at 5:00 a.m. and I have a
show that night at midnight and I was
like why would and and I didn't realize
we get them I'm like wait you got me
playing tonight oh my God and I'm so
obviously jet lag I know you were saying
jet leg takes you two days but on that
one like you're kind of that day you're
like whoa I'm on the other time zone you
flew on the other flew yesterday David
had a bit about that where he goes the
time change is so crazy I land in
Australia I called myself I picked up
the phone
tail that's clean too truly I don't like
when people overuse the goat that's a
peeve but the goat the goat tell
everyone's always like go go no there's
what you the greatest of all time is
usually one and AEL could arguably be
better he's one of a few goats he just
makes me happy you watch him and you're
like this is like you feel joyful it's
you know it's weird comedy concentrate
he's like the the Frozen [__] in the
orange juice can you know there's no
water in it yeah it's like yeah he's
sort of like cuz I remember living here
in the 90s and going to comedy clubs and
even back then like in the mid 90s he
was out like such a fixture and like my
my good friend Jordan Rubin who sorted
my
comu he's great and he was a comic and
he friends with all the comedians so he
kind of got me in that world where is he
now by way he's he's in La writing
directing producing oh great yeah uh and
uh G porn yeah all right he's sucking
his own dick good for him um so okay the
fight so I get to Australia I land I I
have to party all day to stay awake so
it's just like espresso beer speaking of
coffee just keeping it going and finally
I get on stage it was out of a movie and
the second I get on stage um I grab the
mic I'm holding the mic and a dude jumps
on stage grabs the mic and yells
Australia and punches me in the face
with the microphone what the [__] so I
just remember wait did you say anything
ante Australia to proceed this I just it
was the moment I got on stage without a
hesitation he and holding a roll yeah
and he's holding a roll a qu basically
which was I remember back in the 80s is
how you wanted to punch someone so he's
holding the mic and he punches me in the
face and I perfectly uh turned because I
just remember like Turned with getting
punch and I turned and I look right at
my DJ and he just is like oh [__] and uh
it was like slow motion you know time
kind of slows down and like a car
accident or a fight or whatever and I
just turned and the one year of jiujitsu
and I don't want to sound like I'm tough
cuz I'm a [__] but this is what
happened I grabbed the dude by his like
shirt and I remember if it's a t-shirt
not a ghee you you grab and turn up and
trip them and fall on top of them and I
did just that who's who's wearing a ghee
to a well that's their argument in
Jiu-Jitsu is a suit a suit is a or a
jacket be a so this guy had a t-shirt so
you grab it turn it I trip him and I
land on top of him and I just start
bombing on them and it was like
Christmas story when he's beating up the
bully and and and and I'm thinking I'm
beating this dude's ass I can't believe
I'm beating this dud a a circle forms
around us and is going Dirt Nasty Dirt
Nasty and I'm just socking this dude and
I'm like this is the best show on Earth
this looks fake like it was planned and
that was Will
Smith and security grabs me off and they
pull me to the side they're like mate I
didn't think you had it in you make good
technique and I was like oh this is
awesome and then they were kicking the
guy out I'm like no bring him back I
want to get him a beer and they're like
yeah and then it was he comes back and
immediately attacks you again exactly it
just keeps going uh and then the next
day it was in the the newspapers Dirt
Nasty beats up fan at show and it was
the best press ever because then the
rest of the Australian tour is that you
no yeah that's a show but this was in
Australia the rest of the tour is dud is
challenging wait a minute so it's I
don't know if it would be on YouTube but
this so so then the rest of the tour I
had this reputation as oh he he's crazy
he beats people up and I was for the
first time in my life I was just
laughing cuz I'm so not that guy that it
was funny to be in Australia with this
reputation like hey he beats up was fans
be careful with this guy and they had
security for the rest of the tour with
me at all times because like they
thought I was a liability I'm like you
guys have no idea what a [__] I am that
was so [__] it was just kind of funny to
for a week in Australia be considered a
tough guy I've never had that rep now
every Australian has a stereotype that
Jews are tough you
know thanks to you that was crazy so and
then yeah that was uh but yeah back but
to the reality is is I'm really not a
tough guy but hey you took the guy on in
front of an audience
was self defense it really was so
awesome it was it was like I it's like
it would it was almost like all right
dude I'm going to jump on stage you're
going to grab the mic yell Australia
you're going to punch me then let me
beat you up in front of everyone and
then Security's going to P it was like
perfect it was like a plant it was
perfect wow what a psycho so he planned
that I mean what a nut yeah I or moment
yeah he was wasted yeah and then but I
knew the Australian way I was like bring
them back get him a beer and it was like
they love that they love that I don't
know you're doing Australia yeah doing I
did I don't know a couple months ago and
they they yell shoy so watch out oh yeah
you got to drink out of a shoee and I
just kept saying shut up all right all
right but I did like 20 shows so by the
last one I was ready went the sh will
not replace us yeah yeah I met the guys
who started the shoey they're these
Surfer kind of like d yeah they came to
one of my shows and they're the guys
that like pioneer or started this no
actually think Pioneer is such a weird
word for that no I think it was actually
a there was like an argument whether it
was like a famous race car driver in
Australia did it after he won there's
some origin story to why they're shoes
but it's just stupid you're drinking out
of a a dirty shoe I I went out and
bought a shoe I was ahead of the curve I
bought a shoe at Walmart I scuffed it up
a little bit and then they yelled shoey
and I had my friend throw it to me I
caught it and I did it but I did it the
last show cuz it was what what kind of
shoe were we talking it was like a Vans
piece of [__] knockoff white shoe I have
a video of it on my Instagram but what
what's it Tui Vasa whatever said that
UFC guy does the shoey every time oh I'm
not sure but yeah Australia Bert did it
he got laryngitis no [__] way yeah
cuz it's just oh here we go do a shoey
you [__] that's all they
yell and the crowd's going ape [__] so
that one guy you know it's a bad sign
when when bertke Cher's body can't
handle
it exactly let me piss real quick I'll
be right back piss we just got in here
all this coffee the coffee it's the
bloody tequ we'll hold it down Mark
don't worry Winnie can take my mic for
it now there you go see it's a clean
shoe you can tell uh did a package come
boys that I ordered I want to give you
at the end I want give you guys a gift
no I just oh you got them there perfect
we'll do it later just want to see if oh
I didn't know there's a secet I got a
gift gift for you guys so um yeah it's
funny cuz uh you so you just got back
from Australia see this is what I'm
saying I know more about you guys than
you know about you just were in Europe
yes you were in Australia you know more
about me than my father I it's [__]
yeah your dad was a very he was a
businessman you guys lived in a mansion
you had uh that was empty you got robbed
a lot for your bike there was um if I
could remember the trans black woman
that raised you this is scary her name
was like uh Matilda or Olive head or
something GL not not really think of
penis reg enus en enen you can't make
this [__] out you can't make it up and
she hooked up or he hooked up it was a
drag queen mured hooked up with a guy
got murdered in a in a van told that
story a lot though so that one's not
that crazy that's a that's a great story
I've heard that one on a couple
different pods cuz that's that's some
real [__] all right New Orleans is a
rough town man everybody's like you're
going to New York you watch out like no
New Orleans is way scarier that's when
people like talk about how San Francisco
so out of control like yeah it's a
little sketchy but every major city and
New Orleans to me is where like oh
you'll just disappear out here oh okay
can I tell you the B okay real quick one
I know I'm a lot I'm a lot I'm a lot
bring it a lot uh my one of the fun of
the funnest nights of did you have this
dog since puppy days no dog
16 so no I'm saying the dog you got it
as a puppy no it's my girl dog it's your
girl dog she adopted her like oh that's
cool the girl you go to hot yoga with
see I know your life too much hey come
on she uh adopted her at nine she's 16
now I mean she just adopts old she got
the body of a
15-year-old um she feels bad they're
going to you know die in a shelter cuz
people take them back I get it I get it
man you get so attached to those [__]
things I I I found a Li I live in Joshua
Tree and I found this very rare lizard
called The Horny Toad if you want to
pull it up and they're so beautiful and
rare you can sell them for like three
grand to Germans or some country and I
caught one and I put it in a jar and I
live alone out in the desert this in one
day I got attached to a lizard that's
how much pets this was a coldblooded
lizard that do enough about the Real
Housewives no this was a real lizard and
I put it in a jar with a little like
sand in a little fake tree and I slept
next to my bed with this lizard and I
swear I had to let him go the next day
and I was like like I'm actually sad to
let this little buddy go I'm like that
was one day with a [__] lizard
imagine how ATT you get to a dog dogs
they're the [__] best speak of
abortion is that what this is this uh
planed Parenthood okay real quick New
Orleans story can I I'm sorry guys it no
baby um and you guys are let's see that
picture of Pacino that's you guys when
I'm talking
um uh so I go to New Orleans with my
buddy j e and his manager j e is a guy
from St Louis who produced a lot of
Nelly hits like uh Country Grammar
remember that oh do I remember Country
Grammar my boy's like a he's like a
white boy producer and he's like the man
in in St Louis and I'm shooting a movie
in New Orleans he's like we want to come
to New Orleans so he comes down and
we're drunk in the French Quarters
eating barbecue at one of those like
makes [__] not like like just a barrel
like someone rolls it up and you're
eating the barbecue and my boy who's
from St Louis is like man this is the
best barbecue sauce I'm bringing some
back so he goes I'm bringing some back
so he buys a jar of barbecue sauce in
the street and we're really drunk at 2:
in the morning morning and these two uh
black guys come up to us and they go
y'all want to see the real New Orleans
and we're so drunk we go yeah and jump
in their car whoa me a Jewish manager
and this big white dude who makes
Nelly's hits who's a tatted up big white
boy and we jump in these strangers car
and we drive to the hood in [__] New
Orleans and we're so drunk we don't even
think about what we're doing we get
there and we get out of the car and it's
like one of those movies in the 80s like
when Chevy Chase pulls up in vacation to
the wrong neighborhood they're like you
know what I mean like which way to the
freeway man [__] your mom like one of
those moments and we get out of the
car what oh yeah Nelly cut it um
royalties and uh so I we get out of the
car and dude out of this is out of a
[__] movie we walk up to the club
with these guys we don't even we go to a
club with these guys they want to show
us the real New Orleans there's a old
like a trick I didn't think they out
there's an old like classy black man in
a all-h suit out front at the door to
the club we are the only white people
inside they killed
you and and my boy as we walk in drops
the barbecue sauce It shatters On The
Ground all over the dude's white
suit you step on sneakers you're done IM
imagine a white suit barbecue stain
everything stopped everyone looked at us
and it's me and two other white boys in
the hood that spilled barbecue sauce on
the dude's white suit that is the
whitest thing possible ever possible and
I'm just in that moment I'm like we're
done and he looked looks down at his
suit and he looks up and he goes man it
would be the only white boys around here
spilling barbecue sauce on me get your
ass in here and he let us in and they
loved us and they put us on stage and
they had these girls it was called a
bounce Club [__] oh I know bounce so
bounce is like the genre of music in New
Orleans that's called Bounce music and
[__] Nai is like a famous bounce artist
and it's sort of like a it's like Miami
booty base whatever and all of a sudden
we're on stage as like we're the joke
and we're getting these girls Barefoot
are standing on their hands booty
clapping us like we're like we're
pinball machine and we're just getting
Ping ponged On Stage and you just see
the whole crowds laughing and it was the
coolest most fun time I ever had in my
life road trip yeah dude did you start
doing some some nasty no we were just on
stage having a good time and they know
you rap no they have no idea who we were
it was we were a novelty cuz they were
like these white dudes must be crazy to
be in the hood like this who are they
put them on stage and it but it started
with the barbecue sauce on the [__]
[__] suit and I thought we were dead
it was out of and he he let us in it was
it was so how great great they're hung
over and they're like was that the guy
from
Felicity holy [__] there's the little
bounce so was that I was we're getting
bounced on stage it's all twerk music
but I'll I'll be honest I had more fun
at that party than any douchebag
Hollywood [__] Showbiz party I just
don't like you know what I'm do you go
to them I so you kind of have to it's
part of your job you got to go you know
meet people and you know like with it's
you do make connections in this business
are just as important as almost anything
else it's like who you know and when you
go sometimes you're led into like the V
like I remember I went to the Vanity
Fair party the last couple years and
that's where like only the select people
get in and that's where you're meeting
everybody and let me get your number and
you then you do a movie with that person
you know what I mean it's like that's
how I met Todd Phillips I met him at the
Soho the king your boy I met him at the
Soho House the it was the first time I
ever went to the Soho house which for
listeners is sort of a exclusive
high-end Hollywood and worldwide kind of
a it is but it's where like people go
that are you know making money nwork
it's kind of like the first class Lounge
compared to the other rest so the second
the elevator doors open my first time
ever in Soho House One Step twostep Todd
Phillips comes up to me and he goes Dirt
Nasty big fan
Simon get his phone number next thing
you know we're working on [__] together
he's putting my music in his movies he
put me in a movie he pilot I did what
movie uh the movie was called it was
like a party movie I got edited out it
was it was a party movie where it was
the whole thing was a frat party he was
producing it and he was directing it
from on the phone giving me directing
notes while he was doing Hangover 3 and
Bangkok and he was calling and the movie
was called like s [__] I have no idea
dude it's you could find whatever the
[__] you're doing not lying it's a real
movie but I'm not I I think in the end
I'm in it for a frame because we don't
know produced it movie and it's about a
party it probably came out in like 201
12 anyway that to my point that's kind
of like how important those RS are and
how far that could go is just like hey
Project X Project X there it is I
thought this project X and if you get
there's in the DVD outakes they have my
full scene in it but okay anyway but
that's neither here nor there I got to
work with Todd and become friends with
him and now he's my boy and he's the
best and it's just like those
relationships are [__] that your agent
and manager can't even get you you know
what I mean that you got to it's part of
your job is to go like be in those rooms
so totally um I just feel like I have
imposter syndrome like with other actors
I don't feel like I'm really so funny is
you saying that in the
Superman I just feel like I don't fit in
you well no it's true like I but I feel
like I do you guys have this I feel like
I don't fit in anywhere I have this
everywhere no matter what I've done in
my life for a career I'm like I'm not
one of you guys and it's Pro it's
probably just me being insecure or low
self-esteem whatever it is but I don't
ever feel like I'm part of of a
group you know like I know a lot of
comics but I'm not one of you guys I
work with actors but I'm like but I'm
not really one of you guys when I was
rapping I'm like I'm doing this as a
joke I'm not a real rapper Never I think
that makes you almost like I mean fit in
everywhere instead of not fitting
everywhere oh yeah chameleon Style baby
and if you did fit in someplace you
might not be as driven yeah I think that
the not fitting in makes you kind of
like kick it up a notch like fit in even
mean I feel like I feel like comfortable
with Mark cuz we've been friends for so
long but I don't feel comfortable like
the bigger the group the less
comfortable I feel and that's group
think is so dangerous you just see look
everything that's wrong right now is
just sort of large group thinking that's
just so not like I feel like and this
sounds so corny but I'm like a lone wolf
who doesn't want to be in a large group
cuz I feel like that's where that's
dangerous in a weird way like all the
bad [__] you ever see from Cults to
politics to whatever it's always like
group think you know and people say be
yourself you got to find you and then
when you be yourself they're like that's
not what the group thinks you're like
wait I thought we were all supposed to
be individuals and now you're mad at me
for being an individual and then what's
the uh Adolf Hitler quote I would never
want to be a member of a group that
would have me as a
member that's grouo marks but yeah oh
the Marxist right that's what I me there
you go be yourself everyone else is
taking Adolf Hitler there you another
good Hitler quote you miss 100% shots
you don't take big Hitler wait so what
else were we talking about that was
Wayne Gretzky so what does that clock
mean is that this uh Is that real time
or
keep it about an hour right no we going
we go this is a long app this a this is
a special this is a creepy up we got
people coming I love that's great we got
trick-or-treaters um yeah we got kids
coming so you got I know you got oh my
God what is this is Christmas it's red
and green now what is
that shot these are I found hypnotic in
a liquor store speaking of black Club
give you guys the I have the best I got
the best stories I'm hell yeah the best
hypnotic story
dude for the occasion but these are for
you Simon these are tequila Incredible
Hulks okay instead of I got to go to um
my movie premiere tonight I'm going to
be [__] hammered and I got to get on
stage and talk like with in the artsy
fartsy New York Film Festival I'm going
get up there and just be like I just
thought we might be drunk you want to
hire me to pretend to be an Australian
I'll punch you it'll get great Buzz for
the movie no but that seemed fake but
that really happened Simon re does it
again yeah baby are we getting a photo
right now is that what we're doing this
is getting off the rails baby so okay
hypnotic you ready for this one this is
a good one so this girl [__] her this
girl um I'm not going to say her name
cuz I don't remember it years ago Demi
lado um I she calls me up crying this is
probably I remember I had my phone was
the LG phone with the so far sounds like
any
woman this I'm going to say this was
like maybe 05 is and uh I get a call and
I was in New York visiting my boy I was
driving I'll never forget I was driving
out Central Park and I answer the phone
and it was like the LG flip phone days
like and she's crying and she goes I'm
pregnant
no and I instinctively this is back in
the Western Union days Jesus Christ this
is like the old Wild West like 20 years
ago she goes I'm pregnant she's crying
and she's doing such a performative good
job that I don't even think about it and
I'm like oh okay what do you need she's
like just you please just Western you
$350 to Texas or wherever she was I
don't even think about it I do it then
afterwards I'm like wait a minute I wore
a rubber with that girl oh she got me
and I was like well good acting she got
me I'm going to have to just let it go
and what am I going to do like okay and
then my boy hits me up a month later
goes hey this girl's drunk at the table
bragging all loud about how she got you
for 350 bucks and pretended she was
pregnant I'm like this [__] now's going
to get it yes so I go to a club in LA
and I see s murder a woman yeah yeah I
see her at the club black doia that was
him I see and by the way when I call her
a [__] it's Justified at this point of
course she stole from you yeah and and
lied to me so I know yes so so okay I go
to the bartender and I go what's your
stickiest drink and you goes stinkiest I
go stickiest he pours me a hypnotic with
some other syrupy drink and then he
jerks off in it and I go up to her I
just I see her and I go up to her and I
tap her on the shoulder and she turns
around and I pour the drink on her head
in slow motion and it's just dripping
down and she's like and of course I look
like the [__] to everybody who's in
the place in security picks me up and
Carries me out and I get kicked out and
I'm just like it was worth it yeah
totally that is such a real house [__]
someone over I threw a drink on her no
Clarissa poured slow motion it was so
gra satisfying gratifying gratifying and
I pour it on her head and just to look
it was like Carrie like the movie car
and it was just re it was sweet revenge
I love it and it was almost worth it
just for the poor the 350
like good acting on her part I'm such a
d said stickiest I thought that was like
a slang for you actually wanted
something sticky threw in her night I
love it so anyway yeah that was uh that
happened well she probably paid 350 for
dry cleaning so you got her there yeah
[__] I had a girl once uh venmo request
me uh we had we hooked up and she flew
to New York to hook up with me and it
didn't end well like we not like I was
mean to her but I just didn't up dating
on her we didn't end up dating I end up
dating someone else
she venmo request me for the
flight and I was like pay I didn't even
want to think about it I was like you're
not taking up real estate of my mind
well in all fairness my mom is Jewish
and she want um I [__] Simon's
that's yeah that that's the venmo
request o wow we could I I got Peeves in
please we love peeves we it feels like
we're getting towards a venting time of
I noticed on the show you guys will get
into peeves or Rex early and then you
could get back out out of it right we go
wherever the Pod takes we have the
format just to have a couple things to
always I'm drinking HIV here you're
wearing a Superman suit come let's go
nuts okay here's one and if I've said
this on the last
one uh okay um when you're talking to
somebody and in the middle of you
talking to them they get on their phone
oh yeah but here's a rule if I'm already
on my phone and I'm texting and you
start talking to me you're in the wrong
right because I'm already in this don't
make me don't make me feel bad I'm in my
phone you saw I was in my phone but if
I'm mid conversation and I'm talking to
you about like my dad you saying I
just it's like and then they and then
and then after they're done not
listening to they don't they don't even
come out of and go oh what were you
saying it's just lost and you just sit
there and you're just like that that's
really annoying um and I try to never do
that so if I'm like at dinner and I feel
the phone vibrating and someone's
talking to me you just got to let it
vibrate you don't pick it up self
defense versus you know your it's phone
etiquette my girl does that all the time
we like I will be writing a text to
someone and she'll start talking to me
I'm just like you got to let me finish
that's her fault I'm not going to do it
while you're talking but that's on her
you got to set those rules that's a it's
a new peeve and it's a very logical
peeve very logical cuz I was in the
middle of something and you started
talking now I have to give you attention
and if I don't you're mad but you
interrupted me you interrupted me and
you're making it like you're you always
no it's like well no we're always all on
our phone now but that's not the point
it's like you saw me on my phone first
you're you're a horrible person you can
say I'm sorry can I just bother you for
you have to at least address that you're
in the wrong so with an ex-girlfriend of
mine we had to have a talk about it we
go here's the rules and we establish
that and everything was fine so
communication is key okay here's here's
one in La I don't see it out here too
much same face girl every girl now has
the same mathematical face they the same
lips and they're 25 years old doing work
on their face what are you doing you're
and you all want to look like the
same aged that's how I feel that was
literally angled right into my Betty
thought do I go to the guest or he knows
he better I know him better Mark and I
are old friends he's allowed to part my
mouth I wish if I have one I'm going to
rip it rip it up um I got to peeve
people farting in my
mou
uh yeah no same face every girl is
starting have the same face and it used
to be old ladies in Beverly Hills you'd
see driving by in a r over that want to
look like Angelina Jolie they look like
a cat but now it's girls in their 20s
are all getting all this work done and
it's been super normalized and it's okay
it's like no it's not I think that's for
other women because us dudes don't like
that we hate it and my wife is Young and
I she she gets it I'm like what are you
doing is it it's just is it just filler
or bot it's Botox okay so that's women
get prevented guess lesser of the bad
yeah it's more when they actually get
like work done cuz I don't even notice
boat talks and I guess I don't no yeah
they're all the same right they all have
the same face and and I swear it's
almost like when dudes go to the gym too
much you're doing that for other dudes
that's not for women if you're just
funny and skinny you can get laid you
don't need to go to the gym you're doing
that for other dudes it's quite
homoerotic or like spinning rims when
those were things like that a for girls
that's for another dude to be like
you're cool great Point what are you
doing you might be gay dude oh that's
the new show we might be gay and that's
okay that's okay but pretend you're
doing it women because really they don't
give a [__] and the type of woman who
does give a [__] you don't want to be
with anyway who just wants to be you
know what I mean like [__] your quads
bro like yeah I'm with you there's too
many of this like any girl who's doing
this all day oh I'm out it's also
hilarious how women know their angle so
much better than us like Mark and I will
have a female guest and we'll take a
picture with her and Mark and I both
look like in the picture and they're
just like their angle is like perfect
they know what to do they know what to
do they know what to take a photo well I
think part of the problem is these
Instagram filters have made the
expectation so perfect like they could
autotune their face and all these things
that it's like now the the the goal is
perfection it's like the golden ratio
whatever that number is of the the
universal uh Beauty math there's like an
actual mathematical equ can you pull it
up it's called the golden ratio and I
think it's it's like the Fibonacci
sequence which is the nature one but
this is more for women's face that
around the world is agreed as what's
beautiful for the standard and it's the
eye space it's the nose to mouth ratio
it's the width and it's agreed by every
culture is what that is and they're all
trying to get that space But it's not
real so therefore I see right through
you and you're not real and I don't like
you interesting yeah you know what the
craziest one is is uh a lot of Asians
are getting the eye surgery to open them
up and you're like what are you doing
they're doing that a lot and they're
getting skin lightened they get their
skin light they want to become more
westernized and a lot of Americans are
getting their eyes closed to look more
like Clint Eastwood so everyone's a
loser wait why does CL have is he like
this he's always squinting I almost got
my car bashed in by Clint Eastwood I
yeah I parked in his got a Hollywood
Story for everything I parked in his
parking spot at the Warner Brothers lot
in like 1999 I was like Felicity days or
something and I'll never forget his
offices were right next to like where
the friends we were shooting right next
to friends and I remember I had a
Porsche and I was a cocky young actor
and I was making a lot of money and I
was just stoned all day and I didn't
care about anything and I was a dick and
I remember I pull up into a spot and
they come out they run out they go hey
hey hey that's Clint's parking spot if
he comes back he will back bash your car
in with a baseball bat and I was kind of
like I hope he does just for the story
like I want him to bash my car in how
[__] cool would that be if dirty
hairy beat up my car and I left it there
for like 15 minutes and they were so
pissed but I got out of there before he
yeah yeah that was the yeah he that
would have been a great camera lucky
punk o and then on the same lot I played
basketball with George Clooney jeez he
and I swatted him so clean swatted him
so clean he went for a layup and I
muffed it and he goes foul and everyone
on the court goes a and I go really he's
like you hit me I'm like I'm not going
to argue with George Clooney but wow was
all ball wow George cloone movie Georgey
like late 9s but he knew he was on The
Fast Track calling fouls like that so
found find out later cuz I would play
pickup with these guys and it would be
like some of the grips from a show and
some of the we know and Clooney would
play but I remember one day I'm playing
out there and I guess who he was very
contentious with him always calling
fouls that weren't really fouls and he
was you hear the same thing about Obama
he called a lot of fouls is that right
yeah it's I I think when you get Super
Famous you feel entitled to a foul call
I think you're right and also I think
like yeah you you everything else goes
your way so just I would think you'd
want to be humbled in the opposite way
but maybe not but anyway I this so this
[__] grip or some cons one of the
guys who wasn't an actor and he calls a
foul uh uh um Clooney calls a foul on
this guy who's obviously like a blue
caller tough guy was working on one of
the sets
and Clooney gets the dude in headlock
right what and and he's like this and
and I was like oh [__] and immediately
the guy reverses the headlock and gets
cloone and one and is on top of him like
this and everyone goes no no no no no no
that's a $20 million face don't do it
and I remember seeing Clooney's face
just sticking out of the thing and this
guy was going to muff him up and I was
like oh [__] and the dude didn't punch
him but he just had him clean and it was
like a basket Hollywood fight almost
happened and I was like this is
incredible a rough game as he did it
Matt Damon was walking out with all I
knew you were going to come no Clooney
uh by the way Clooney should do this
podcast I feel like he's a casamigos guy
he's a liquor guy I feel like he he's a
comedy fan I heard him on Marin and he
was cool as [__] he's a big comedy fan
the universe George Clooney come on we
might be drunk we're fans we're big fans
of your work yeah and your wife yeah
and out of sight one of my favorite
movies great movie Out of Sight that's a
great movie he's awesome as a bank
robber in that also Elmer Leonard good
director too yeah so oh El more Leonard
is there a movie about him coming out
wait is there really he wrote all those
all those cool books oh never mind I
just read one of his books and I'm
confused there was the Detroit bank
robbery one I forget the name that's a
lot of his [__] he's great he's great
great writer but dude uh I got what you
said about stars coin [__] I know a guy
who played in a pickup game with Kanye
West and apparently he called goal
tending it's like old dud you can't jump
and he's like go tending that counts and
they're like what it's like call three
in the key he like come on three in the
key Kanye call go wow I do think Clooney
should come on this pod though that'd be
great we'd love to have you The Facts of
Life I'm trying to think of a Kanye joke
cuz she ain't messing with a gold di She
ain't messing with a go tender hey I
like it I like it he's back with Adidas
you see that mm yeah they they forgave
him oh after the PO anti-semitic rants
really uh that he won't ever make
another mistake so I'm sure this will be
a longting partnersh I think with Hamas
he doesn't look as bad that's true you
know so he's looking pretty good right
now I don't think he was doing us any
favors but yeah there's there's bigger
villains out there for sure yeah that
Alex Jones thing you know what's bad
when Al what Alex Jones thing oh he went
on Alex Jones and like defending Hitler
and even you know what's bad when Alex
Jones was like you got a take he was
like you got take pump the brakes man oh
man ah Sandy Hook wait can
I bunch of I hardly knew you I started
off I want to do a bit this bit never
worked about Sandy Hook but about how
like if there's if you believe in crisis
actors do you believe in crisis actor
agents like some guy like she's
incredible she was in Sandy Hook she was
posible for PSE nightclub you
know that's [__] great cuz I got a
couple of friends who are really big
conspiracy theorist and in the peak of
coid when there was like people crying
over a lost loved one I would they'd be
like that's a crisis actor I'm like well
I'm an actor and I could tell like
that's not that's real that's not a
hired actor like to orchestrate that
like there's no talking to those people
but it's okay I have a lot of like
magical thinking friends which is you
know that's kind of what surfaced during
coid was a lot of people that believe in
some other [__] you know whatever teach
to but that's actually a big peeve of
mine is trying to you know like have a
conversation with someone who believes
in all of that CRA you know they believe
that crystals will heal them and they
kind of fun though because you're like
just go it's entertaining you know you
meet a flat earther
that's a good attitude to have it's like
I I wish I could be entertained more I I
get I don't know why it bothers me but
it it does well it's it's it's maddening
CU you're like what are you crazy but
you're also like let me listen uh oh
wait I think I got how about another
crystals if crystals are healing I want
to see you uh with a guy with a gunshot
wound yeah exactly put a little Crystal
next to him let's see what happens some
cancer yeah you guys probably can't
relate to this one but this is more of
the rest of the country might relate to
this one cuz you guys are New Yorkers
but you do Drive Drive oh yeah so
there's a thing when you're driving and
uh you're you're supposed to keep like
you know a couple cars distance between
you and the car in front of you in case
they slam on the brakes you got to give
a couple little bit of breathing room so
I'll be in the fast lane and I got two
car lengths in front of me just to be a
normal human and somebody Zips in to
fill in that spot and they're risking
your life yes and they're filling in the
space and that's kind of what causes
traffic like the accordion effect of
like it all backs up and it's like if
everyone just stayed in their [__]
lane and did be an [__] we'd have
less traffic and and and every time it
happens I got to try not to get mad but
it's like dude you filled in my safety
zone dude and you're [__] it's like
not cool but it's in New York I don't
think you guys get that one as much no
no I'm I'm with you on that the the're
too close to to pull in just the fill in
guy or the guy racing next to you and
you're racing to a red light like where
are we going well there's a comfort with
the with the distance that's fill it in
you ruin we're talking about my life
it'd be like if a guy at a movie theater
he had the whole thing to yourself and a
guy said right next to you like what are
you doing man happen dude to bars people
the bar the [__] is that they wantang
there's two type of people the people
that are in the airplane that don't
notice there's 72 people waiting and
they're slowly putting their back away
and then there's me who's like like I
don't want to be in your way let me like
you know I got one crazy I was in an
airplane and it was me in the window a
lady and the empty seat we're taking off
the seat on the aisle is empty I go hey
look at this we got the why don't you
scoot it over and she was like I'm good
I'm like come on hit the hit the aisle
[__] stay middle stayed middle I
couldn't believe it was like my God for
a second I thought Mark went the other
way that she was in the aisle and he's
like come closer no no that's why it
took me a second take the aisle what are
you crazy she stayed in the middle for
like it was a [__] flight from Vegas
that's insane this one must have been a
peeve on the show before is when you a
long time ahead reserve your aisle or
your window and a couple gets on and
they're like excuse me would you mind
switching your seats so I could sit with
my like [__] you guys live together
take a break for 2 hours I'm not giving
up my window seat so I could sleep [__]
you and now I'm the [__] when I say
no [__] you if if it's still an aisle if
I go I go if it's still aisle I'll I'll
give it absolutely I will give you my
aisle right but if you're trying to get
me to go window for
window that's my point like it
Windows what I say I say [__] you kiss
my dick one time this happened to me it
was like Miami oh sorry I didn't mean to
no no that I was going to say kiss my
dick a few more times very important I
got to get t-shirts um some merch going
well I so I met someone in the middle
once I uh this Miami couple I was in
Miami flying to LA and this guy gets on
with his wife and kid and they're like
can we please sit in and I go no and
then they made some big stink about I go
how about this halfway through the
flight I'll give you the seat so I was
nice to that's a compromise that's a
compromise but in my mind I'm like don't
you want to be with you do you really
need to be next to your you guys live
together take a [__] and just like
and no off but it's not my fault you
didn't book the [__] together like why
is that on me what am I Expedia now to
change the flights Expedia but like I
had this with a lady she goes hey I
think they know I'm weak they go right
to me and I'm just sitting there I got
my sunglasses on I'm hung over I'm gay
and she's like hey by the way you sound
like a very weak person right now I'm
weak I'm weak and she's like uh hey oh
uh oh he's no it's hot it's hot okay
it's starting to get hot in here it's
the very uh what's the cal um pooc
costy well it'll make you thinner made
by Hitler what the [__] you go boss I
think he he did that design you go boss
to make cuz they did dress good they
looked amazing pull that up well that's
yeah the Nazi uniforms are uh I mean
evil as [__] but yeah I mean they look
sharpo boss has a great cut I won't wear
it out of out of oh really no cuz you
know what it's like yeah I get but then
would you drive a Volkswagen I think
it's different I think Huga boss was
like the Nazi
manufacturer I look you could cut holes
in what I'm saying A Million Ways I'm
just if I see it it's also expensive I'm
like I'm not going to drop a lot of
money you know that's a peeve these guy
and I might lose you guys on this but
these guys who buy like a $60 t-shirt
it'll be like a black solid t-shirt 60
bucks I'm like I go to hannes for a
black tea yeah maybe want I mean for
like TV or something sometimes it just
fits better I get I still don't get it
I'm like you can't tell the difference
between my haes and that Hugo I get if
it's like tattered or has a loose neck
or something maybe but the straight up
black te for $60 I don't get it do we
have do we have any I love this Nazi
with free Wi-Fi by the way how'd that
work are these
NEOS I guess not all right but yeah um
what about Rex Simon I got I got a peeve
please literally every person weighing
in on every issue on social media wel
the internet the middle west the middle
middle west the Middle East like
literally the dumbest [__] people
mest the the dumbest people are like
here's what you have to do and I'm like
some bodybuilder in Tampa figured it out
you're going to Sol the crisis in the
Middle East between like I get the F
yeah everybody yeah we're going 100
years stick to giving me bench set tips
all right like wa in Mia Khalifa weigh
in and she lost her deal with Playboy
what a dumb [__] though I mean like I
mean truly like you know you're a p you
know you're a bag [__] when Playboy's
like we can't show your [__] anymore
you're too big of a piece of [__] wait
Playboy still around I didn't even know
I thought it was over it's like a
Prestige thing it's not like it's like
you doing Fallon It's like got it got it
I did show my tits on Fallon yeah you
did doing this hot yeah you're getting
halfway naked just like your Clark K all
a sudden CL yeah that's that's really
annoying as everybody it's like it's
like can we all agree you said this once
actually Sam yeah could we all agree we
don't know anything especially about the
most complex thing most complex experts
are at a l you don't need to have an
answer for everything and just
regurgitate something you saw on the
internet and think that you know like
just just be like I don't know and exact
and I'm not even saying like if you want
it if you want to post like this really
upsets me that's totally understandable
you should be allowed to do that uh and
if you want to say like this is [__]
up on both sides here and we're we're
you know mourning the loss of people and
terrorism is horrible but like the
people that are just posting like here's
what I think you're like
well I don't want to know but for some
reason it's been upvoted but it's just
more uh well that's why we're not
solving this on Twitter is my point like
like if you're striving for you're not
changing anything and you're just
singing from your soap box to it's about
you you're making it the you show you
made the midle it oh speaking of peeve
ah here's one o when a girl posts on
their social media or whatever them like
doing charitable work like like some
white girl with like 30 black kids in
Africa like smiling like [__] you're
saving the world get the [__] out of
here you're [__] making it about you
you only did it for the Post it's kid
you you don't give a [__] about the kids
you even picked one where you look hot
in the middle of a sea of children you
sick [__] yeah I mean literally the
second it's over she's like all right
scan exactly yeah that's it don't touch
me e unbelievable can't do it sort of
tagging that I've got one celebrities
pretend like they're down to earth oh I
love that [__] is that me when it's
paltro and her Oscar is propping up her
door oh
how is that down to earth she's
pretending like I'm not impressed by oh
I see I see it's just a door stop to me
yeah Shakespeare and love anyway it
doesn't really count hey get in here
jordo hey liquid IV folks you don't have
to be an athlete to need extra hydration
throughout the day liquid IV's got you
covered with three times the
electrolytes as a leading sports drink
and eight vitamins and nutrients for
everyday Wellness no matter what you up
to liquid IV will keep you hydrated
hydrates twice twice as fast as water
alone so it's now available in three
sugar-free flavors white peach green
grape and lemon lime no artificial
sweeteners just get an amazing flavor
without the gross bitter after taste I
got a pack of these at the next to the
kitchen sink I do one every day just to
get the uh the juices flowing when I'm
hung over I do two and the flavors are
great I like P colada or strawberry
really white grape I I do this all the
time too hangovers sometimes you just
like hit the gym a little too hard s it
out it's great I love it sure and a lot
of coffee is a diuretic I think and
diarrhea yeah grab your liquid IV
hydration multiplier sugar-free and bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 20%
off when you go to liquid iv.com use
code drunk at checkout that's 20% off
anything you get when you shop get
better hydration today using promo code
drunk at liquid
i.com NBA fans aw is over basketball's
back and draft DraftKings an official
sports betting partner of the NBA has an
unbeatable offer new customers can score
$200 instantly in bonus bets for
throwing down just $5 on the NBA make
things even more exciting with draft
King parlays string together multiple
bats from the same game or build your
own parlay against multiple games for a
shot and making the payday even better
basketball is more fun when you're in on
the action download the draftking
Sportsbook app now and use code wmbd
that's wmbd for we might be drunk new
customers can get $200 in bonus bets
instantly for betting just five bucks
only on draftking Sportsbook with code
wmbd the crown is yours sorry Braun [__]
the Lakers go next gambling problem call
1800 Gambler or visit www.1 1800
gambler. net in New York call 8778 hope
Andy or text Hope and Y 467 369 if you
got a problem I guess but you guys don't
have a problem problem gambling's fun in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 888 78977 77 or
visit ccpg dorg please
responsibly on behalf of Bo Cino Resort
Kansas licy partner Golden Nugget Lake
Charles Louisiana 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario bonus bets
uh expire 168 hours after issuance see
Sportsbook . draftkings.com
basketball terms for eligibility and
deposit restrictions terms for and
responsible gaming resources thank you
guys
nice Jordan get over you're sober
right Jens Simon you have a drink right
fellow comedian in New York drink okay
we'll drink for you do mushrooms you
super lesbian what's the outfit here qu
I'm oh you're oh Doug funny I'm queer
man
Kon lady do you remember this dog is
deceased no basic she's hanging in right
at the end don't you ever say that about
little Winnie oh my God she looks like a
John the booker of standup New York huh
a little inside but yeah
yeah uh Simon's half naked cuz he's uh
hot it's very hot material I'm actually
embarrassed I met you once and I played
myself in front of you really bad I
remember I came up to give you like your
credit after a standup show I saw you do
you sitting with you're friends with Lou
right yeah you were sitting with Louie
and I was just like I was just I hate
myself and I come up to you and you were
sitting there after set you murdered and
I just reached over and I thought that I
should come give you your props and it
was just like very unnecessary no no it
was cuz I could tell like even you and
Louis were just like why is this guy
coming up I went to your little booth
area it was at the cellar downstairs
that little area but the other around
the corner and I had a couple drinks I
think I was even on mushrooms and I was
like I'm just going to go tell her she
and that happened so I apologize you
don't remember this no okay see I've
living with this there's nothing wrong
there's nothing wrong with you saying
good set like we love that did you force
a fist bump yeah yeah those are that was
brutal the too close to the face one
yeah that happens the forgetting s well
she never even remember so no oh jeez
I've been living with that every day for
well no one noticed remember they're not
thinking about you s is that it's
alcoholic she doesn't drink virgin this
this one's I wish that somebody would
she's a virgin so mushrooms but no booze
is that's yeah mushrooms acid I'll I
mean I can't do Molly cuz I'm on too
many anti-depressants oh gota oh really
but booze just I don't know can you
orgasm I get no that's what I hear I say
they say antidepressants you can't orgas
I can't even well maybe that's the
problem that's my Seinfeld what a deal
with these anti-depressants the women
aren't coming well it's ironic cuz women
are in anti-depressants to make them
Chill on enough to date and then they
can't come oh well they couldn't come
anyway from my experience the G-Spot of
that mask is tight on oh it's hurting I
am hurting really I broke mine I luckily
got a I got his Incredibles mask I'm
going to take this off and turn Asian my
eyes are being pulled back I did acid
with my Dad recently what who are you
one mytim L
J with my father that's a fake tit watch
out it's uh soaked in in boo on accident
yeah that Mark it was weird man it what
was that like it was weird uh I would go
shroom before acid with with see I used
to be shroom before acid but actually
acid and means cleaner shrooms get me
more heady and acids cleaner are you
guys have a good relation working on it
okay that was part of the whole thing
for you yeah it was Heavy though man it
was the second time we've done it my
dad's like an old hippie so it's nothing
for him to do psychedelics but uh it was
weird it was weird of course but be wor
you would get too honest I never wanted
you the abortion clinic was closed that
day your mom's a [__] whatever exactly
you know but it it was wild but uh I'd
love to do as with my dad now that he's
dead that would be really just looking
at the coffin yeah staring at it out he
that was always a thing he was like you
can do acid but you have to do it with
me and I was like that's the scariest
thing I wait did he really say that yeah
because he was a hippie but he was
worried I would jump off a building
which was very true where did you grow
up Ithaca I was going to say Upstate I
feels like an Upstate hippie dad thing
to do yeah and we and I did acid tripped
hard and it was a near death really I
was on the front page of my newspaper
what pull it
up somebody walked by me and they went
you're famous and it tripped me out and
then I got home um type itha Journal
itha Journal
acid and my last name is spelled with an
E [__] just Kidd jeez come on Sally
and uh and then you look like divorce
right now this is pathetic I got laid
off I mean Wolverine I'm an IT guy now
squinting at the
computer okay so what do we got here
itha Gazette dad that's my dead dad oh
this is hurting
obituaries yeah I don't know how you
pull it up Jordan Jensen maybe no
Ecuador that's what it was for cuz I
didn't all right so what happened okay
well I saw myself on the front page and
I thought that that meant that I was
supposed to die that day oh shut up what
the hell do that mean I was like today's
the day I'm supposed to die it's all a
cyclical thing so then I locked myself
in a room uhhuh and uh and went in and
out of being like no I have to seize
life and live to the fullest to no no
you have to kill yourself immediately
back and forth forever yeah and then I
came out of it a new person and haven't
done acid since hey there you go itha
you got to do acid what else is there to
do I'll do all the time I did them the
other day skankfest and oh I heard
everyone's on psyched dogs there huh oh
yeah that's like a big druggy thing one
of the comics was so [__] up that she
touched a black girl's hair I saw that
that was so oh you were there for that I
was there I was at a strip club it's
funny I tried to write a bit about it
you can touch everything there it's full
nude you can finger women you can't
touch the hair though that gets you
kicked out so funny damn who is the who
who did she T it was wi chank the poor
thing and I was trying to explain to her
I me and who she touched though a friend
of my friend a lady at the club black
lady yeah and she was we were trying to
explain it and I was like yeah I just
and W Ching was like but why and I she
was asking why is she mad and but I
thought she was saying why can't we
touch a black girl's hair and I was like
oh no idea that is Way Beyond got we
going to take the sit down and talk
about that one for a while it's a long
answer yeah we don't want a bunch of
white people to be breaking this one
down who knows I think it's fine next
subject Pho Robinson get in here I'm
Jewish oh you are cool Mark uh atheist
yeah gay trans yeah ambig stuffed in
there huh no this is a sock nice but I'm
Ambiguously Gay so I wanted a hog yeah
but I'll take it out I feel the two
actors that were the two who was it
again batty igly do it's Robert smel was
Steve Ste Co is that right yeah wait SM
did SM why Smigel wait Smigel wrote it
oh I got to just do a thing with him
what you got to do a Triumph the insult
comedy dog song live at Largo in LA and
they I did a Sandler song that they had
done 20 years ago was like a Sandler
singing with the dog going back and
forth and he was like well you do
Sandler's part of the song and I got to
sit down with them and like rewrite it a
little bit and perform it live while
Triumph and me were riffing back and
forth and it was like one of the [__]
coolest things ever it was at a strip
club comedy show that they do in LA at
Largo that was anyway it was cool and I
was just honored to work with yeah me it
was one of those
things it's a 250 fix that that is just
out but yeah that's so fun yeah it was
cool to work with Triumph I mean that
was he's a legend pull up some pull up
ComicCon with Triumph or the Star Wars
line no how about the uh the wiener
Circle what's thater Circle when he's in
Chicago at the oh yeah yeah yeah they're
all great he's excellent Smigel is a
genius I mean he's yeah he's excellent I
don't know who any of these people are
you know you know smig no what the
insult dog listen oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
he wrote for uh SNL for a while no no I
don't think so he's out there I thought
he was there reporting on maybe January
6 or something and got put inil for me
different guy different guy that's I
know who you're talking
about the part where they touches her
hair is brutal
here is that Zack uh mcre or whatever
Jack MC Jack
mcer Jesus
Christ oh my god this is my dream it's
just a a guy behind this hand by the way
that's the beauty of he's just standing
right there saying this [__] the fact
that they're mad at the puppet is the
best part yes
yesal where he comes
from thank you thank you what what is
that there water this suit Is My
Kryptonite I'm dying in it Jes it's so
hot there's something hot about the
muscles sliding off revealing the skinny
man underneath yeah you're in pretty
good shape though son I saw you you I
mean ass naked in red rocket you you
were running I was like I do just I just
do uh Jewish prison push-ups that's all
I do body weight prison push-ups not
trying to get just want to be flexible
and mean and lean and be able to run
away from danger well the Holocaust
invented
bickram all right okay I don't think it
was I don't think it helped anxiety
quite as much that's good point so
you're into hot yoga now man I I go my
girl likes it so I'll go like I'll go
like once every two weeks it's just I
don't stretch so it's like an excuse for
me to stret you got to stretch it's
humbling I like do you ever do stuff
like that or no I just came from Pilates
whoa you came I came came from doing I
have come from an exercise machine once
which one which one elliptical this is
so weird this is so weird I could do it
right now if we had one pull it up when
well the proac um you go like this and
you lift your legs up like that yeah oh
yeah on your stomach or your back you're
on your back like this you're holding on
oh and you just do your legs up dude I
have no idea there's something about the
blood pulling down and it crazy I've
done it like multiple times we had up
man it's sad when you can't get your own
wife off and she goes to [__]
exercise class and she's [__] all
over the flooor man could never say that
like I I hit the plotting machine and I
came all over the
place I'm not announcing it I'm not
being announcing really good class thank
you Martha I came actually three times
you're in a Planet Fitness oh no
grunting no grunting they P the lug [__]
what is it the lug alarm lug Bell I
think yeah lug Bell yeah is this really
a silicone tit is that is that you who
sent us this you know who sent us these
tits I already I had about 30 pieces I'm
going to be so titties uh Simon is uh is
Trey Parker from South Park's wife does
she likes the pot I guess so why does
she have these she's a doctor or a
surgeon oh okay oh oh really yeah the
[__] power couple wow I know power coup
that is the dream that's the dream is to
get Trey Parker match Stone on that' be
great okay so yeah who's the dream
speaking of dream
guest
hey oh it's
Prince Austin bers is escaping a series
of me
toos Austin
white he doesn't move his legs like this
we went to the
r something do I make you Rand here sit
down we're got to move the boarded baby
here hold on we
go how the hell are you you know Simon
I'm good
hello Simon Simon Ian good to see you
both uh both funny guys yes I'm very
excited this is exciting to have you
here buddy good to see thanks for doing
it e of velvet and cigarettes yes I I
got changed here on the
street changing that is such a good
costume did you bring that they brought
it for me I I asked for it you really
put the man in the quail man who's
Quailman by the way is that quiddit from
Doug quid remember Doug sker Doug
cartoon I remember it yeah I'm to I'm
old to my generation Doug Doug and the
Rugrats were holding that Network down
for a while Temple of
Doom
Temple hidden temple
temple Legends of the Hidden Temple that
was dude the best part of that show is
when they were trying to you pull this
up salak when they're like competing in
the end and and a security guard would
just like grab them oh yeah you think
once the guy was like this is a great
way to kidnap kids I would love to go to
have like G where are they now of the
kids that Ro yes that would be great go
to a lot of GRA it was a cool or a bunch
of double dare people what are these
double dare people they all it was
educational too they do like real
questions you'd have to move up all
right now we sound like pedophiles have
another shot kids were really attractive
whatever that green monster was yeah
that you know what I'll do Mark you do
one more I got I got a full
IV a little oh no I have some left relap
already no you didn't no I'd be sucking
everybody's dick if I had you know what
I mean how
longer right yes um how long have you
been over off alcohol oh since uh uh
October two years when did I get into
the seller two years ago two years ago
hey look at your whole life turn around
well I had not been drinking for a long
time and then I got in and I had a glass
of wine oh she's talking about the wine
seller I had a GL of wi to celebrate and
I didn't like it so I kept going but
that was the last time I drank you feel
better right just don't like it I get
[__] I get sleepy my face gets red I
get puffy and I always like yeah I hang
out with people you end up doing [__]
you don't want to do and you're like why
did I do that just yeah that's true do
what about does marijuana do the
opposite and keep you out of trouble or
do it make you insecure and paranoid scy
yeah yeah bite my tongue off let me see
should I bite my tongue off right now
should I peel the flesh up my yeah isn't
that weird but okay so you really are
not left with much cuz no alcohol no
weed occasional mushrooms mushrooms are
the best I don't need anything besides
mus but the right amount mushrooms you
love mus you were F I'm not me I don't
do any of that you I can't do mushro Dr
your Drinker You're Sober what you
drinking this is not alcohol how long
you been sober eight years good for you
dude
2015 I understand how [__] hard that
is i' think I've gone three months is my
Max just on three yeah you are so strong
you can't even fit in that little I know
I'm busting out of the scams here dude
no it's it's literally the hottest we've
been here for 4 hours and I'm getting
more what do you do are you in a
relationship right now no what do you
guys do on a first date as sober people
tell them I go I I don't drink uh we can
get coffee or go for a walk they like
but I feel like sobriety's hot right now
like people are going sober it's it's
way more popular than ever I guess like
I'm not going to Comics what yeah what'
you say I don't go on days I just hook
up with Comics who've seen my entire act
and know everything about me so they
know that approaching me is terrifying
and then I'll hook up with a girl and
then a couple days later go I've been
listening to your podcast dot dot dot
dot that's the
worst but at least they know you at
least they're like well I've known every
bad thing he's ever done and said and
I'm still willing to [__] him I've had
fights with girls that I date over [__]
they've heard me say on podcast I always
wondered if that happened you're fishing
yeah I've never and this is not a slight
on any woman I've ever dated I've never
I usually spend so much time with them
that I've never been like you know what
I need to do in my spare time spend more
time with them yeah that's what a
podcast crazy lady [__] I would never
listen to a podcast a woman I was
[__] I always wonder when you guys
talking sh I'm like are there girls
listening on this they must PE
sometime yeah I've got in trouble for a
bunch of stuff I got in trouble with
Matt Richards recently I got in trouble
with a guy that I was dating because I
said libertarian stuff I um what a guy
got mad at you for that yeah that's
that's a deal breaker she dates absolute
puss oh really this guy's any guy was
like an appropriate like all right we
got to go girls who do that or they'll
go you didn't refer to me as your
girlfriend you said that and I'm like
you going to kick rocks lady but also
don't stop blowing me try to tell my
wife that don't put stuff in their act
because of it because of their well
that's why I had to stop dating people
because I was like look I'm having more
fun now than ever that I don't have to
be like do they work but when I'm in a
relationship I I do not talk about them
personally I very much keep that
boundary up but I me neither but the
second we break up I'm like like I'm
going to bring this [__]
now the second go out Jordan turns into
a [__] Oracle of just life she [__]
over Trevor Bower I don't know if you
heard about that what
ised dude I felt fake titties at
skankfest those big fake titty girls
they let me grab them all over they're
hard as a rock hard as a rock I I don't
love it yeah it's not great the first
time is excited I remember I hooked up
with a girl with big fake tits once and
I was like the first time you're like
this is incredible then you feel real
tits again you're like yeah I'm going
back to that's how I feel about trans
women how do you I need to go back to
the organic how do you feel with Jo de R
Roa getting all this love good and
you're like I've been doing this for
years
and F FW because of it you know what no
hey good for D Roa he's finally
realizing he's cool and he's a friend of
Finance I support it let's go more guys
need to go to the other side did I at
skang Fest he goes like this he's like
he's like we're talking upstairs and
he's like yeah Joe D Roa you know he got
blown or sagalo is telling us you got
blown by this transwoman D and um and
Ian goes she she would have blown me she
would have blown me too if I and we were
like no that's not really the director
we're not going in like isn't he a lucky
boy we're going isn't he might maybe a
gay man well he loved it he's all in now
does that mean you're gay or I mean I'm
a novice stuff it doesn't
just drugs and sex and rock like what's
the I've never
been is it a lot of drugs and [__] is
that what's going on what is not [__] is
it Burning Man for Comics what are we
talking about there's very little comedy
happening it's a lot of podcast oh so
it's more of a party there's no it's a
big party it's basically everyone that
pays for Louis's Network gets like their
dream to come true once a year they all
get to see they get to meet Sam Talent
whoa make a wish for people that are
going to hang on for a few more years
yeah exactly
no it's great it's it's all these comedy
fans go they get to see you do stand up
Podcast you say hi you say hello it's
really fun it's a for all the comics
gamble com yeah and we all get to hang
out cuz we never really see each other
all in the same place so it's it's
really nice for everyone I've been
hearing about it for years you don't
have to censor you know sometimes you go
in a green room you're like can I say
[__] around this lady probably not uh
but skankfest is just full on go nuts
and there's no industry there so you
don't have to like have conversations
with people you don't how long until you
think they'll go to that though cuz it
seems to be Emily was there The Comedy
Store Booker was there but she's cool
she could hang but yeah Lucy were there
they're cool they're different they're
alcoholics and fun lady I mean they're
strip clubs putting La 20s in laia yeah
and we had a thing they had each night
was like uh uh someone hosted a party at
the strip club and uh two you ran the
[__] show man it was this guy can run
a strip club it was impressive I was
watching distance T that black hair we
uh we they gave us a bus and uh I
rallied the troops I got us all in a bus
we went to the strip club and it was I
got to be like a mother hand of like
ushering people over I was giving people
ones I was like have you had enough
Patron okay good do you need some ones
okay it was so fun imp you gave me the
$1 bill is to give the strippers but I
was on mushrooms so I would hold it out
to them and then they would flip their
butts into my face and it freaked me out
so much that then I would disappear hide
behind
is tjer and the women thought that I was
like grifting
theming first of all Jordan goes what do
I do I go you throw it at so she
overhand throws a dollar bill like she's
in a [__] League of Their Own and to
be too close and then a girl popped her
ass over and when she twerked her [__]
fell out and Jordan went and she just
scurried
away it's weird I'm not a big are you a
strip club guy no I was thinking about
that earlier how I'm not because I
forget why I thought because it's very
uncomfortable I don't know where to look
do you look him in the eyes do you look
at their tits do you look at their butt
what do you do comfortable I know but
it's weird and and and the people it's
very I just look at the dudes in there
and it's sad sure well I like going when
it's a group of friends and I get to see
them interact I'm not going to be like I
want that
one feel like I'm getting hust it's fun
thing want to pay to get a hard on I get
a hard on for free I can't get hard so I
was I was going up and going may I give
you a piece of currency my lady not like
that they not
Jordan so one go I don't want that she
threw it on the ground she walking
through like a DCH with these huge kids
he goes a currency for you and she goes
I don't want this he gives him his
dollar back it was a Best Buy gift card
let's be honest you're drying up
strippers with your character
work like [__] The Improv guys are here
again I go I'm like Baka and I start
talking my ass those strippers were
aggressive man they were trying to make
a buck and they were not taking for
answer I break up once and I went to a
strip club solo in Minneapolis and I was
so depressed I was so I was playing AC I
was I was soad I was like I don't know
what else to do I'm alone I'm and I went
and all the women that came up to me
were like too young I couldn't do
anything they one of them's like she
must have been like 22 and I was like
I'm sorry do you have anyone like older
and she was like really and then another
woman came up to me and she was like I
guess like you know she's like she I'm
the oldest one here I was like how old
is she like 27 I'm like I can't do this
sounds like a great strip glove what the
hell are you talking about yeah really
where I'm where's this location yeah Oh
no just a question yes um Simon
statement rather uh I went to a strip
club in New Orleans yeah when I worked
at MTV in the 90s and this kid had never
been to a strip club he's really young
we're like he's like what do I do I'm
like give her a dollar he put four
quarters on the shut the you can't bring
the the temple to that [__] strip
club holy [__] all there's a strip club
in New Orleans not going to say which
one Hustler but they do a thing where if
it's your 18th birthday they bring you
on stage and if you get a boner
yes you get all the money I you get none
of the money cuz people are throwing
dollar bills on stage but if you don't
get a boner you get all the money so my
friend we went for my friend's 18th
birthday basketball shorts
ATM as to mouth and that's that game
that we used to play what was it called
SP dick where you would like slowly
chicken no you'd get closer and closer
and closer until they would cut you off
yeahi small gay chicken you go like this
until you tell me to stop okay well I'm
going to chicken myself yeah thank you I
was going to let you go for the for the
bid all right so what happened we have
volume up it's terrifying like thank God
I have six pairs of underwear on Mark
it's hard we lose all our
subscribers no that game has a name
chicken when you put your hand on
someone's leg and go to touch their
penis they say have keep yelling the
same thing me it's not going to make me
change my mind it's nicotine it's called
chicken chicken you're not being able to
see through your gogg
it's called chick give a go I I don't
know this game did you guys ever gay
chicken gck gay chicken or is I called a
turkey
sorry nervous it's called nervous tell
remember it tells a little bit about
like uh what was it about chicken and
fish that's what's healthy I said we
start serving
penguin tell's always got the bested got
it the other night the other night Ari
walked through the the room at the
cellar and goes Ari you look like the
landlord of a box
a what a poetic way to say homeless what
the [__] am I smoking here sunset
sunset have a little
Sunset that's nice I'm okay take I'll
take the real thing this is all us
spreading Co right now yeah really super
spreader oh my goodness oh no I want to
guess who this guy he's good really he's
good yeah Mentalist yeah oh boy bre or
anything I'm good is he going to read
our minds I think yeah what does a
mentalist do God you want to see a real
haunted house open that thing
up be the scariest episode you ever
recorded she's got all the look at me I
have to
go ghost of babies in there she's grown
on you I see oh my God wait whose dog is
that Gizmo it's not Gizmo who is that I
just realized she's a hot dog g lizz's
dog oh right right Li is an old ass pug
too isn't it weird that they both have
old pugs are they're surrounding your
life maybe you have a maybe The
Mentalist can tell you why that's a good
point you know maybe your spirit animal
is a decrepit
ancient half blind dog they're just such
fun dog I love Pug's face are like
comedy man oh yeah it's like they have
such comedic faces a funny looking dog
with the tongue out the one eye bad rap
they're the same as French Bulldogs
pretty much but now they're the hob yeah
but they're not supposed to exist that's
they breathing neither are you okay
they're God they're like Chinese emperor
dog so they're supposed to be like right
by your
[Applause]
side The Mentalist costume terrible I
showed up yes all right give the man a
chair how you doing sir comedy doing
this feels like a Kyle dunan character
come on sit
out there we go get get a mic on uh the
mental oh you got one okay so Oz AGT
Alum right here oh I didn't I didn't I
didn't go very far on it though you're
too good for them oh well I don't know
about that but the guy who beat me was
actually an incredible mime he that guy
tape face face he's incred he's Inc
Vegas re people were like you lost to a
MIM and I'm like tap face you're like oh
[__] he's
good feel bad for the poor woman who was
abducted she's like I can't watch tape
face it brings me back when the guy
[__] put me in a sell for n years too
well you how far would you go at us was
he was he talking during that behind the
scenes or what he talk to me good
question yeah I he tried I don't know
what they do to you but try to get you
to talk [__] about your fellow
contestants and I'm not going to do it
watch you and have ceras on you and have
you talking [__] behind the scenes while
you're watching them try C like get a
gotcha moment with your face like oh
that sucked what did you say what is I I
don't quite know what a mentalist is
please so I mean should we get in itri
let's get this going I'm the lame one
who can't drink I got a gig right after
this I thought this was tomorrow so
Superman what's your name Simon Simon
what's a mentalist right seen MTV
where the [__] have you been on this
guy's royalty what's that nothing pick a
number one to 100 69 obviously for Ian
why are you showing me my name oh
because that makes it sure that I'm not
thinking of Ian okay I got I got it I
got it I got it look at this struggle
right here he didn't let's go here
what's your name
Jordan so a magic trick is like I would
do something right now right but there's
no trick one question okay and if you're
just listening to this I just wrote a
number did you all see it you I see it
but I'll screw it I saw it purple The
Lure you're out you're good at what you
do one to 100 was there a reason you
picked this number yeah see look at this
I bet damn do you think he did a
birthday this guy hasn't blinked in
minutes I think he might have gone
higher oh he's a nut Sam Crossing this
off this guy's coming in hot I'm gonna
go what's your name ay Coy's watching
like a hawk don't tell them the number
yet grab the marker let me see I didn't
even know there's a dog in here I wrote
12 she's right here kill me it wasn't 12
was it is this the camera we're we're
filming at it's that one cuz I want to
make sure I show it to the camera was it
12 and be so mad at myself tell me tell
Jordan tell Sam what are you guys
supposed to be by the way with The
Ambiguously Gay do it's not that
ambiguous okay yeah uh I'm kidding about
you go Simon what about Austin power
bottom 49 tell them what I wrote please
you s tell them what I wrote I crossed
out 12 I wrot down 49 oh man what' you
say 49 is it to the 49ers and I'm 49
years old that means we're winning the
Super Bowl this year and he got you are
winning the Super Bowl oh my God how'
you do that the NFL Mentalist bro I've
been on with every team how you you do
that you guys not seen these clips guess
her age will you no ages she's 12 I
don't get slapped come
on definitely not going to look up to a
great joke from Sam I I love the Tweet
where you go the guy made fun of you and
you go is that you with a duffel bag
with your act in
it one in 100
chance where's that theud how did you
guess I did a g with I G with the
magician and he was kind of a dick and
he goes oh are you going to uh what did
I say to him you you know it more than
me what is it I'm fan uh something where
he goes uh you have some good jokes in
there and you go you oh yeah he goes
you're the one who telling jokes I said
I'm the one who didn't bring a duffel
bag that was my J on which I did say to
a magician but you know hell yeah how
did you guess 49 that's weird you know
how tell usk I'm not going to tell you
hold on to this hold on to this I saw
Mark here's I want you to do think of
someone don't think of your wife too
obvious I never
[Laughter]
do sh baby yeah think of someone if
you're having a birthday party and
somebody you invite but you'd want them
to be there so you know maybe not I got
it no I'm kidding uh you got it someone
I want to be there who I know somebody
you know somebody you know you got
someone got it somebody that you know
what if they were having a birthday
they'd invite you I hope oh a different
person okay okay all right all right I
got it you know what J down go over
there write this down I don't want I
don't want anyone to see she's watching
behind this guy qu hasn't blinked in
minutes I don't trust him yeah this
impressive write down this person's
name I love how these guys so no phone
number wait do you know this person's
birthday by any chance oh that's a power
move even if you know the month even if
you know the month chaos or your
concentrating and then they do their
little first and the month and whatever
day you think it is I won't fact
and uh I mean this is a [__] group
I'm this is going to be a big up I think
I'm EXC what are we doing here now
there's no trick I just want to get of
Mark you know he disappear murdered Mark
oh no no you hired a
murderous you coming back Mark sorry all
right now I'm a stickler oh hold on Fold
It Fold It fold it in half come on back
yeah baby I'm a stickler before you say
anything you didn't write the last name
did you no so even if you show them they
might not know who this is come on back
I'm good how you know I read the last
dude what the [__] is happening with you
man this is crazy the N word that works
this you know what I'm glad we didn't
about God for I was nervous about that
one oh God Jordan since you're onom me
grab that note yeah do you think she
knows this person yes don't look don't
look then don't look you definitely know
him him saying him what's your name d
hold out your hand grab it take a little
yeah take it all make sure I'm not
cheating let me grab this myf had a
birthday party would they invite you
yeah I think so I think so too you know
what you just thought of it watch his
face October November December January
February March April May June July look
at that expression right there do you
see that bam you know what you do when
you think of who you're going to invite
to your birthday you got to go Tit for
Tat did they invite me the person you
just thought
of what month is he born in oh good
April April that's what I thought wow
The Mentalist what the [__] is happening
man give it away I got no Poker Face
how' you give it you know what I think
it's a friend of the podcast I know who
it is it's Gary verer isn't it wow how
the hell did you do that what open up
the wall scared scared open up the wall
if it's a photo of Gary I'm kidding uh
don't take my credit card what the hell
she doing she's a woman this around wait
no no no okay open up oh my Lord if you
got a picture of Gary in there I'm
calling picture Gary and there should be
a c and a zipper and read the note on
the back to Mark what the [__] wish Gary
happy birthday for me oh my god dude
what the [__] is this man all right I
don't know how he did that this is what
the [__] is what kind of sorcery [__]
are you ping bro you didn't write down
on anything to me am I or am I not a gay
man we can all answer that one we don't
need a mentalist for that does even
count if you're on Molly I don't think
it does Ian yes picture this you got a
cast and crew in this room we got some
Bodega cat whiskey by the way everyone
needs to go to that website that amazing
this is a bargain a bargain you got that
right I wanted the 200,000 Scotch but I
decided I'll I'll I'll Splurge baby
forget about Mark forget about Simon
who's still hurting based on the 49ers I
think they're going all the way by the
way I everyone thinks I think so too all
right you you I impenetrable go that's
that's let's not go there uh not his
[__]
whiskey let's say you could sit down
visualize this and everyone I want them
to know before you came out of that
elevator did you know who I was what the
hell was going to happen ever met me in
your life spoken a word CL I thought you
were a magician well I brought a steel
case in if you could sit down have
dinner Jehovah winess I want you to
Picture This visualize this yes ultimate
celebrity dinner guest you and this
person hanging out Dead or Alive man
woman anything gender fluid hold on your
dad is not a celebrity all right Jesus I
saw you go there I know you okay all
right I'm gonna read this guy I said
dead or alive Ian's got a smile from ear
to ear he's not going dead guys Sam
Real's got dead guy Vibes written all
over him
joyard coh as a
child I think it's a guy I think he's
alive it was a woman you'd be more
excited and you know what's crazy about
this is that I've met this person not
once but twice you be honest you did not
tell anybody this you haven't written
down nothing hold on hold on stay right
there you made me look them up in the
green room close your eyes close your
eyes look at this if if you pick this
guy I'm real okay okay he came up
earlier
actually this is I just put this up I
justan he just thought of somebody I
pulled this up cuz I had this can you
see that Peters that come clear no it is
be for real who are you sitting down Ian
open your eyes you're picture in it
what's his name who is he should I say
it first open your eyes open your eyes
say
it are you kid [__] up how did you
[__] get that
how did you get that dude oh we were
talking about him earlier how did you
get that
[__] just
got that's really [__]
up you write it down no I See Stars
right now Ian just starts beating the
[__] out of us with that cane like
[__] witches oh
man got KN he's got a knife it's
serrated it won't go
deep what the the mic oh no I broke your
mic I'm sorry wait did you manipulate
his P did you did you talk to him even
win's paying attention now look what
you've done I didn't touch him
any you got to tell us how you did one
of those tell you everything we get
really drunk and then tequila is my
drink but no I'll drink right get drink
get a drink wait wait whatever you want
here's what you do we got to move the
mic down just a little bit sure did you
win atg uh you should have third third
okay well we got
very ring for very high ranking how how
do you do hey you're you're meist how's
this Israel Palestine thing going to
turn out man uh not good for either of
them not good for anyone it's it's a
mess yeah doist get
serious but on another
note things are looking bad yeah yeah
you're going to read his mind okay how
about it okay okay do this shake hands
it's getting weird I don't know freeze
right there freeze right there just til
gets awkward okay Jordan look this way
you're my Witnesses you are not going to
guess what's in his head cuz I don't
want to know sure you're not going to
guess a name a number a celebrity I've
done it
allita express that was insane it's
going to be watch this if I reach over
and I brush this across Sam's healthy
head of hair oh yeah you're going to
feel something right there in your hair
if I poke his knee you'll swear to God I
poked your knee whatever he feels you
feel like like oh finally you
come j him off to complete him for the
love of God she needs somebody blow this
man for
me that cost extra okay you ready sex
draw no look this way oh Jordan close
your eyes too sex talk can everybody see
Jordan don't peek did you just feel a
poke on your right forearm did everyone
see me do that tell Simon Ian still
shook from Bill murrr you poked mine
right yeah did everyone see me do
that show us on they T her eyes are
closed you peeking all right I need to
ask you a question her eyes are closed I
want you to tell everybody right now
what happened what I do to you you poked
my right forearm no after that you
brushed my the top of my nose
oh
my messing with me right now was that wi
hold on hold on hold on do you feel that
you my cirles clock on sorry eyes eyes
tilt your head up look at her eyes she
is not peeking I want to know when do
you have read receipts on your text no I
never touch them Simon is sweating
Superman's about to ripped off Jordan no
peeking okay how about H H suck me off
real quick yeah yeah yeah in the name of
magic did you feel anything yet no how
about right now anything no my theory is
that the moment I do something to Sam it
goes through his hand I don't know why
he's wearing this gloves it goes all the
way over to her do Jordan Open Your Eyes
Open Your Eyes Open Your Eyes what did
you just feel something right here
oh
what the hell's going
on his nose and his chin this is voodoo
no no no no no no anyone can do that do
it all right now we got to do Rex Rex is
having a mental breakdown close your
eyes all right ready here okay so uh yes
Jordan and Sam hold hands okay Sam shut
your eyes shut your eyes Sam okay so
Simon's still upset okay and uh whoa Jew
Jew beard over here he's crazy okay I
still thinking about Bill Murray Mark G
okay now Jordan uh here here I was on
AGT here
now Sam I did not touch you your eyes
are closed what did you just feel on
your face something in my ear yes it
close to the ear you have
just close to the ear no because what I
was feeling wasn't a tingle it was a
direct paper on my face guess I did
guess damn it guess you don't have the
powers reached over me did is it
possible that this sleeve touched me cuz
maybe he has a no no no he was far away
from my face he was on it he was on it
you could manipulate get your phone you
could I don't know oh here it is you
could manipulate a witness who was like
where on the doll was I touched thisy
here's my phone I just pointed the doll
bro I'm so impressed this is incredible
Was A tingle
was work or no
th% I thought he took the paper and went
over my face wow context we need to
discuss at some point the I don't want
to say the name who hired you who's got
like kind of a fetish for Comedians and
magicians and brought you over in New
Jersey okay in the middle of the night
cuz I've done that gig multiple times
awful gig Orthodox juice amazing I don't
know
what look through your people look
through cont this is incredible context
what do you got Cosby was his body close
to mine wasn't he leaning over me yeah
does he have a tail heavy P there is a
tail it's it's a nub it's a kind of
hurtful to call it do you ever tell
anyone how you do these things my wife
knows a lot I'll you right now so what
do we got I don't know you know what I
don't want you looking through and being
like this guy's an [__] hav talk to
herand no no no do this tip down turn it
downwards okay look this guy flexing
with the MX Platinum right there get in
Sky clubs Black Card start scrolling
okay no no no other here do this hold it
for a mark look underneath damn this
thing's heavy is it scrolling yes don't
linger in butt dial can you guys see
this Simon make sure
make sure thing is scrolling here's what
you do you
scroll no what oh start scrolling no no
it's uh he's got like a cover screen
look at whenever you're done say I'm
done easy there G Spot bring it close to
your body G right there no close to you
right there let me ask you a question we
give him a book right now he opens it
where do your eyes go when you open a
book middle of the page top or bottom I
would probably go to the top I don't I
always look at the middle what do are
you do yeah everyone's on a book bottom
botom you're both I from the bottom baby
come onow hanging fruit guys that's
another thing you could have called
him you want name at the top do this can
I talk more 30 seconds see if it timed
out look at the list see the name at the
top wherever you landed I talked to look
at the name at the top that's what you
want do you know this person I don't
better even better lock your phone you
got people know you don't know's popular
guy okay 100% didn't shift posture
nothing it's a guy am I right it's a guy
it is yeah it's a guy for
sure think of his first name it's not an
email address is it no okay email it's p
ass a hot mail on a jce person uh think
of how many letters are in the first
name see how he nodded did you see that
Simon it's too fast he's aot too fast if
the name was Ian you don't count you
know if it's three or four letters come
on next time it's Mitchell Alexander you
got to count it's four letters isn't it
uh it is oh my Lord I get [__] wrong G
Veer again again hold
on you freaked out when he did that that
was super funny it's not Gary it's not
no but when you did that you got scar
you looked over at him hold up be for
real Sam you took your phone out you
scrolled anywhere I said pick any name
you said I want top name bottom middle
anywhere in there you could have picked
anybody you didn't write anything you
didn't whisper anything what is this
guy's first name Greg
Greg
how one or a bunch I mean my brother's
Greg but other than that your
brother know think of the last name
think of the last name sounds like he's
a member of the tribe but it's
questionable Jewish I can't tell by the
name nobody's
[Laughter]
perfect Jord so met thisy I'm freaking
out like five years ago click later and
you're how the hell I know him who' you
pick your whole phone what's his name
Greg
H freaking me out
evil is fun anymore I've worked really
hard to get away from this was a comedy
podcast scaring me you'd think You' have
a better suit I mean after all that come
on man Jesus this is insanity this is
crazy you can you tell us how one of
those works I want G what are you K is
Simon just robing as the show continues
I've seen a whole lot of collar bone all
one that I can't I understand a few of
them yours I can't get yeah how that cuz
you didn't write it down did you no made
me look at it a picture of them earlier
in that room did you hack into the Wi-Fi
or something is there a Wi-Fi I'm not
even on Wifi N I don't know does what
does Wi-Fi even mean does anyone know
wireless fidelity does that mean what he
showed you picture I like it that's good
he made you what do you mean did
something happen back there in the in
the waiting room he goes Google yourself
now Google Google he was already
Googling himself for the
record Google yourself now Google one
person Dead or Alive you want to see
have dinner with and I did and he goes
okay just keep that save that I'm like
all right yeah I need the photo so
how man this impr I want to know I like
I like it being a mystery I I disagree I
got it
now this is incredible very well done
impressive scary
weird can we have more is it something
that you're born with or is it a learned
behavior uh I bought a book on Amazon
Prime like six weeks ago no but truly is
there something as a child you're like
I'm going to tap into some dark magic no
I did magic I mean this is like 13 I
need to find a way to attract members of
the opposite sex and I'm like C tricks
are working really well right now yeah
you ever work at the Magic Castle no why
you don't it's not that's that child
play I like your pitching him ideas yeah
come with me kid I got to cruise I'm too
much of a capitalist that that requires
a big pay pay cut so you're freelance
yeah good what do you do corporate gigs
corporate and TV oh you must clean up
Podcast a lot of podcast when do we get
on Rogan I have not got on Rogan on
there you should be able to know this I
know can you do stuff I did Shane Shane
gillis's podcast they they were shook up
in Queens man you just hide something
behind your back and Y dog [__]
gay carts are gay shaking dude's hand as
soon as I touched the chin it
was can you do one more yeah let's do it
don't stop keep going [__] do it
close your eyes he puts his balls in
your chin you're
gay think of a letter it's a t and it's
a bag
do do do rex rex rex let do another one
let's do another one so listen he
thought this is funny because every time
I do this I write down a name collect
names and I write down names of famous
people that people are either fascinated
by or want to meet yes okay mostly alive
you know because I don't know it's
primar here's what I want you to see 50
cards Ellen De Jenner Tom Cruz Beyonce
Justin Bieber Brad Pit is everyone here
familiar to you science ran goling you
just got aroused okay Jimmy found opra
anyway you're pick somebody but I can't
have you just look through and say
that's my favorite cuz now what if I
looked you up what if I follow you on
Instagram it's too obvious I wanted to
be spontaneous
random you can see them all and these
are reach
in randomly grab one random grab one
random Rand random random random random
get one get one got one hold on hold on
one more one more I you wanted the last
one so go hit it grab one go are we
supposed to see these yes yes yes cover
my eyes so I don't see a thing cover my
eyes oh my God don't say it show
everybody show the cameras make sure I
can't see is it your dad's name me both
of us show both of us show whatever
everybody whatever I have been saying
this guy's name so much I was going to
get this tattooed the other day remember
and Mark look at these cards don't tell
me they all the same men women ath black
white gay everything I don't know the
gay part but Jord can I open my eyes
good temperature well moisturized I'm
not putting Sam's hand on my face sorry
is put it back get sneaky in there he is
dude both both both but wait you're
going to shuffle put it in put it in
okay she said okay you do it e easy
Shuffle like do like a like a shuffle
whatever are we getting all this all
right where' the van go who knows let me
grab the cards you should know where
that is get rid of it all right if your
pursued walked in the room right now
would you recognize them instantly yeah
huh there's a celebrity that i'
recognize watch watch look at that hand
posturing like this he likes the person
trying to pretend not to yeah there's a
little it's mixed body language M he is
MI definitely a guy well manicured Ryan
goling you Ian you said you want a
tattoo so how about this gang you want
to end on a high note what's what's this
card card yeah not that exciting I give
this to you goes in your junk dra you
forget about me no no no no no you're
going to remember this for while ask you
to do our podcast hold on finish the
thing before you start booking scissors
here we go I'm starting with hair oh God
oh God you do what this guy looks like
this is this is this I'm going to sh oh
baby in studying at the University of
Michigan oh my God this ising your
person's not smileing first time in the
whole thing Ian's not smiling your
person serious and you know what else
earlier you thought of Bill Murray
didn't you out of anyone you thought of
Bill Murray alive and well but right now
you're getting somber on me my man I
think this is a guy am I right could
have been a man or a woman a guy tell us
who is it that you're picturing at this
very moment you said you want to tattoo
I'll do you one better what's his name
say it Elvis Presley King everybody say
hello to Mr
Elvis this is
insanity holy [__] how is this possible
wow I've been talking about Elvis so
much lately the king dude King Simon
looks just devastated this is it's just
you know what it is it's just weird and
it's not fun
anymore can I I'm giving you this hold
on I'm getting a little little something
to take it home with this is [__] you
must be good in bed no you don't spit it
out spit it out Jord Jord knows how you
she knows how you did it you freak she
knows it he went like this with the
cards and they all had a difference of
names and then this stack right here had
the same names and he gave you one and
you one right so explain this idiot do
he knew you were going to pull Elvis
Presley that's still impressive yes
really still impressive wow that's
[__] I mean that's a good Elvis clip
too dud that is wild I had a print of
Elvis in in framed above my television
wow crazy in in in a gold frame and so
does every 18-year-old M goth everybody
you talking about nobody has that not
this guy is special he's a mentalist and
he said it was a guy he doesn't see
gender so that's really impressive are
you sober no no I so you could be
intoxicated and do magic very much so
great story drunk drunk magic for me or
for the a for you to be drunk can you
not good I'll tell one the best stor I
used to car on tricks specifically for
people that were either super high or
tripping uh and I was in Amsterdam pre I
was in Amsterdam pre everything being
legal this like 20 years ago uh and
Bulldog Cafe all these Americans were on
shrooms dude best moment ever there's a
trick I do it's more of a card trick
than it is a like a mentalist trick
where you hand somebody a card they pick
any card of a deck they hold it in their
hand I say whatever you do don't blink
and I snap and the card goes from being
regular size to Mini H and this was like
the maybe the seventh trick I did for
them so they were already pretty shook
the dude on mushrooms literally looked
at the car looked at me left the cafe
they couldn't find him for three hours I
had to go was actually became kind of
sad but it was still a great reaction
that's what my dick does
around those many don't worry we find
him by the way Mark touched my dick
earlier in this episode that was very
funny I feel it Jordan feel it her went
like her [__] flopped a
bit this was a [__] this is a b shut
up where how do you follow that is that
where do we go from that like where do
we go from that like where do we go from
I don't know where to leave you at this
point I got to like disappear and go do
a gig got make us come or something so
okay so you tour the world yeah
primarily corporate events can you talk
to the dead I can I don't talk back this
is cool man it's fun stuff fun stuff you
seem upset I am I'm perplexed I just it
doesn't make sense you came in a great
mood I now I'm
just can I hit your Vape yeah man who's
going to win the election which one
coming up the 2024 Trump okay yeah what
are you going to do there you go that
should honestly be his motto what are
you gonna do it's me what are you gonna
do I'm win great material for Shane
Gillis though
that will the Phillies win the World
Series I'm not I'm not I love Bryce
Harper I I mean I'm I'm out cuz I'm a
Yankees fan but man he's fun they're a
fun team the Phillies I was uh I was
watching I just saw a clip of uh Dan
santis on Bill Mah and he goes how's the
campaign going and Bill and he's like
it's going well and he goes let's be
honest if it was going well you wouldn't
be
here that's a pretty funny moment great
line great line wow yeah damn the Santos
is so unnatural he's not great live He's
not natural you got to get his
album um any like what are the coolest
uh you say you do sports teams what's
the coolest sports team you've done do
you watch hard knock
sure episode two I did something with
Aaron Rogers do you see that thing no
are you the one that told him not to get
the vaccine yeah that was absolutely you
got to watch it I I just don't want to
spoil it he uh should I tell you what
happened
you he takes deck of cards I tell him
look at any card think of it uh I'm not
doing it for you right here so you're
going to be like do that to me right now
and he looks at any card and say close
the cards hold them in your hands tight
and then I I he just holds up is that an
Achilles the [__] it was a snapped
Achilles it was a
photo h no too soon so literally I got
about 100 textt messages and tweets
after be like did you [__] do this
damn yeah and so I told the guy next to
him here's a list of 50 animals that are
never teams like giraffes zebras
goldfish like teams that know NFL pick
one just open the list pick one I go
what' you pick he goes a goldfish and
then I go open your hands when Aaron
opens hand there's the deck turned into
an aquarium like a little deck with a
goldfish swimming around
oh wow I can't wait to see
that and then next week I'm on uh michig
game Michigan Michigan State College
game day with college football fans is
coming up Packers I do a bunch of stuff
in the NFL wow why did you pull stuff
off Ian's phone earlier because I would
like to do that with people I
date scary like this guy is just a
friend of mine SL Mentalist but I'm
going to need you here on second date
date still okay second date skeletons in
the closet if I promised you that I
would not tell anyone it's going to
torture him will you tell me how you did
that thing with the phone
job this is like my Larry David moment
where Larry David has the Cur enthusiasm
where he's like the kids like how'd you
learn this trick oh yeah like a magician
told him he's like I'm a magician he's
like no you're not the [__] I'm going to
ring your neck have you ever met Larry
David he was dressed as Superman that
kid I haven't just as good person Justin
good in person yeah I met him once I was
terrified he's pretty tall 5'11 oh
that's tall I looked it up man he's you
met L DAV I met I I told it on the Pod
last time he was complaining over $1
about a golf ball situation viral Sim
Buzz dude yeah I'm I'm I'm I'm actually
a little buzz but more just in fear and
shock are you trying to figure out how
he did the trick yeah it's more just
like how yeah annoying anywhere in this
room a book we don't like to read I
think so would have been shocked if
there's a book somewhere you look like
Superman after a
bender he's got him after going to
Mexico for a week he just saw through
the wall lowest Lane [__] someone
else he's like I'm done [__] wish I
didn't know the super power you look
like Superman in Hollywood
land have you ever gotten fought because
of this fought yeah has anybody been
like I'll fight you not really fought
but I've had some weird moments cuz I
used to work at a lot of mob restaurant
mob restaurant back in the day and so
they'd come out of jail and they'd have
these like parties where it's like a mob
party where no wies invited [__]
shine box yeah it's very shine box ass
you have this like look where somebody
gives you a look and then you just
realize you're just kidding but it got
real serious we mine comp and Offerman I
dude you know what I think of is you
know the scene where Paulie Walnuts goes
to the to the guy you can see
psychic there all kinds of bodies and
he's like where the [__] did you figure
that out he started throwing the
chairs God bless Polly walnuts man Nick
Offerman has he been on here on the most
recent episodes let's do it so here do
this you didn't know that
me should have known Nick Offerman
[__] rules we love him and he bod had
a nice plug too this is his face is this
good stop somebody stuck this note in
here so I don't even know is your uh oh
what who wants in who wants it get
Jordan in
yeah Santa Claus to be real she's like
I'm gonna figure this out damn it is
away I'm not Harry Potter she's uned
presents Simon yeah let's each you get a
book who wants which which one you want
of these two books they're not mine I
give you these she's going to dissect
this I my books have I I will be giving
you our books
okay here's the game plan here's the
game plan okay we're going to do this in
two ways are there photos in the middle
yes all right I don't want you know what
he's going to pick for you here's all I
you do yell out stop stop look at that
page tell her what number it is tell her
out right now out loud 300 wow want 300
30 good you go 30031 30031 not enough
Pages not enough P damn it be a little
more
premat yell out stop
182 okay well I I on but go to that hold
it close to your face that's
187 still got me problem 182 we got it
stop me Biden's age here we go and I
want you to look at the first word on
the page well was another Ste here
statistically the first word might be
the and if he the like like threel words
two letter words boring is it more than
three letters yes okay same deal you
pick any page I don't want to know the
number nothing I'm going to stare Sam in
the face no GE stare at me as I kind of
riffle stop wait I'll go slow slow make
sure I'm not looking at him no stop
being you okay stop wait do you want me
to stop or
just is that in the cell good photo stop
do me a favor look at the first word on
the page up here yep do you see it yeah
I do is it more than two or three
letters it close the book close the book
close it all right I just picture this
every night at your house with your wife
she's shut up and just eat my [__] all
right with the
games it's false on so many
fronts how many fingers are in you right
now jut up shut up just put them in hold
up your [__] all
[Laughter]
right oh boy it's a Mexican I I almost
want to get this wrong on purpose
because it'll cheers Simon up no no keep
[__] with them ready for this
yeah pick letter mix up the letters in
your word mix them up and just grab one
somewhere in the middle grab that letter
out you got it yeah look at me H you
think of an H you Chang I know you so
well hard
R think of your word it was a weird one
wasn't it he liked it you know why when
I said stop on this page it was yeah
you're good like he was happy because if
it was an easy word he would have want
different page you stopped anywhere
anywhere think of the first letter think
of the last letter what' you just do
either it's either J or G is it end in a
g interesting it's a
j yeah yeah J with a G Jay with a
G be honest Jordan no tricks on this one
because she wants to figure it out what
happened to you picked any book he
picked a page wait you Chang your mind
in the middle what word did you pick
weather weather no he controls it no no
sir you know what I feel like doing I
feel wow like we need to just make it
rain Make It Rain and you know
legal tender tendering is it tendering
tendering what kind of word is tendering
what the hell
[Applause]
man what kind of word is tendering what
the [__] is happening word wow he grew
up in the tenderloin Love Me Tender
that's an
Elvis this is how conspiracies are born
you're not helping the Jews with the
control the weather thing moly oh my God
what the [__] the balls I thought he was
writing down his this episode this
episode is off the rails he got that
right sh how did he do WEA how did you
not open with that one while you
memorize every damn person God damn it
all right even Winnie's enjoying
this Dr o everybody holy [__] you got my
vote yeah you're not thank you sir that
was amazing thank you so much really
killed it Inc I mean unbelievable what
are we doing here I think we're hugging
it out
Simon take his wallet take his wallet
awesome you want any candy candy for the
road yeah hell
yeah let's do this pretty impressive I
don't know what's going you're looking
like a chick that just gave up right now
yeah you got your high heels in your
hands Luther right
now I don't know if you know this is
packed with kryptonites uh oh my God
Kryptonite wow the menal is also
sexual
predator is it possible for a non-jew to
be a mentalist or is it only I there's
not too many there's something inside of
the water in Israel I don't know what it
is all magicians like David Blaine David
Coffield
Houdini he's a Jew that's bringing on
unnecessary suffering that's we've got
enough going on yeah there's no need to
put yourself in a box right dude David
plane I like it back we're back [__] you
DAV get the [__]
out the Mentalist
[Music]
everybody osor yeah how about David
Copperfield all right there you
go thank you everybody check your
pockets yeah I know right oh my God holy
hell that something else the [__] did he
do this that gu be way more famous i'
never heard of him he's doing very well
she's examining everything in her hands
off to he flapped you the book and then
you said stop and he somehow managed to
switch it to what he wanted yeah and
then that he knew the page number on
mine I got it all figured out either way
he was good at it really good e either
way woman ruining magic for all the
fellas right now come on magic magic
magic magic Just Another Woman fellas
have fun come online having a nervous
breakdown you're literally about to
throw yourself off a balcony like how
did you know people like
Elvis how did you know that was sad I
listened to him one
time yeah I feel like Ian is like the
perfect prey for a magician I mean that
was literally could have been like
violent you've been like my
grandmother's Dead Mother's cousin was
viol how did you find that guy Peters no
I booked him I got oh that was you good
job good J you think I don't have this
podcast's best interest at heart we had
D Roa eight times we could have had him
Ro is dead weight hey that was awesome D
is The Mentalist I'm [__] sad I don't
know what's the point that's yours man
so this is my first time trying BEDA cat
I remember you guys came up with the
name you guys were exploring names
were're like and it became BEDA cats
yeah we had fat cat but that was tast
yeah yeah BEDA cat I'm going to try it
for the first time oo
baby 12 years sober down the
drain smooth tasty it's got a hickory
undertone it's got a nice Auburn Cherry
bite it's good flip it from
Tyrannosaurus Rex baby baby Jordan if we
had a whiskey it'd be called rat juice o
That's tempting
rat rat fat cat Bodega cat Bodega cat
why do you want fat cat originally it
was Fat Cat I think it's just like it
sounded like high society and silly and
new fatat we were thinking of things
that are like what makes you happy when
you see it and no one's not happy to see
a fat cat opposite direction you went
from Fat Cat to broke ass [__] no who
tell me who doesn't love a bodega cat
[__] everyone loves Bodega sorry sorry
sorry I love catch no they pop in from
behind like a cereal box and you start
petting one you're like this is [__]
this is the best this New York baby so
yeah Boda cat became the thing bodegacat
whiskey.com folks yeah baby and uh we we
should WRA this up quick plug mg theater
November 4th please come to that [__]
New York City baby is this plug plug
time and then I got uh I got the there
the sweet East is in uh limited theaters
December 1st a really fun movie they did
and guys I was offered a tequila
sponsorship didn't do it I was operative
Vape sponsorship didn't do it I chose to
be better than you guys and go healthy
with this so I started a men's skin care
line called MOX okay and it's basically
just the same kind of [__] that you use
of your girlf or your wife stuff all the
time it's face wash and a serum and it
keeps your face looking younger and
healthier and it makes women more
attracted to you or if you're gay other
men attracted to you so it's black yeah
exactly so I'm going to leave you guys
all with a box of my new company mock
skin care I'm trying to do something
positive with my life you look
incredible for 61 than thank you very
much uh so anyway yeah this is my new
company that I uh I am actually
co-founder of so it's not just like oh
I'm working with I'm actually part owner
no dude you do look incredible there it
is always MOX yeah baby no wife no kids
is really the secret but anyway what
does MOX mean it like Moxy oh Moxy yeah
you know got it and it's good stuff so I
got all you guys a boxy of Moxy
boxy you can use it to it's bisexual
true true hey so is she all right well
we love you Simon I love you guys thanks
for having me on this was a real
Whirlwind is oh is it world
worldwind
so you're whirling in the wind yes check
out with
Jord b& with Jordan our podcast I can't
wait to come on this one yes
F new episodes every Wednesday
patreon.com bnm pod November 3rd am
Music Hall come and see me in Long
Island and guess what I'm recording my
first special December B Cutting Room
two shows Ean finance.com for tickets
and all my dates thank you Jordan filmed
hers there and it's [__] incredible
check her special out it's great
everyone watch Jordan special on YouTube
right now Jordan's hilarious I love the
fact that Lewis put these out and his
are the lowest numbers that's fun yeah
it's hilarious yeah Jord special so good
check her out y Che out should I plug
dates plug dates plug anything I'm
coming to LA in October I'm coming to
Cincinnati Utah Burlington I don't know
this comes out Rochester Syracuse I
really wish I could fart right now on
the mic so hard Rochester Syracuse
Albany is the triangle of sad right
there it's only one nighters in each go
supporter Jordan's hilarious so is Ian
and uh uh I'll come in Australia uh next
month November I'll be in Australia all
month uh Brisbane Adelaide Melbourne
Sydney and then I'll be back at the end
of the month uh Tampa Vegas at the win
[__] let's go and then uh Fort
Meers all that [__] buffalo I'm back in
club minute the special is going to be
in March at the Wilbur in h Boston but
I'm coming a bunch of places before
there so come see me on the road I hope
you come out of Philly Springfield
Missouri all that [__] do you jack
off in every hotel room you think oh God
right it's part of the
deal all those when you're in a
relationship you're like let me just get
the poison out oh here here I remember I
told he was drinking Sam's poison I
remember I remember a young comic was
like how do you not cheat on the road
and I was like I just jack off before
the shows he was like yo that's [__]
genius I was like I know if it's genius
I think it's just I think it's just a
thing you do yeah yeah well right Mark
nooman comedy.com I'll jack off in your
hotel and uh the beacon in January come
on out sell two shows and get some
Bodega cat beard Boda cat I'm this is
good stuff I'm not just saying that cuz
I'm here it's good stuff guys I
enjoy hell yeah look at that all right
what's the Japanese word for after you
come to be clear there's a word I did
and I you got to do it on the microphone
you stinky son of a I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry went through the Velvet you wash
your ass do it I didn't fart The
Metalist made me do it that'll stick in
your nose for a while you're
[__] but it came out all right I sh
out a little Milky Way there but uh
going give me pink eye one of these
weeks well thanks for listening happy
Halloween we we truly do love you guys
for for staying with us every week and
he smells it over there what a special
and and uh and if you haven't seen also
another shout out watch Simon and red
rocket which is incred he's incredible
in it and uh thanks man and and check
out all his stuff coming out and he
can't plug everything because of the
strike strike good stuff happening good
stuff happening and uh and And subscribe
to our YouTube and and leave us a nice
review everyone and we appreciate you
guys have a happy
Halloween Sunday day for my
nextend a bit of know the beard close
I've had a little
[Music]
too Up on the Roof like a cop coming and
naked Samu is feeling
danger I'm out to lunch here in New
Orleans this woman doesn't look like I
remember
and I get down in the same
way we
might
be
true